and another day another junior
speed chess championship match
i'm grandmaster robert hess alongside me as
per usual grandmaster daniel naradiski dania
yesterday we had an absolute thriller of a
match between nihal tsar and anton smirnov
today is going to get even better with our
matchup between sam sevion and alexis serrano
it just might robert a pleasure to be commentating
with you today and another amazing day of action
up ahead these players and i i say this every day
and i really mean this every day uh these players
are incredible every match holds the potential to
be just edge of your seat entertainment and so far
every match has delivered and robert knowing
these players there's absolutely no reason to
believe that this match also will not deliver oh
it certainly will and we have our smarter chess
match predictions which are brought to us by chess
goals see it's a pretty even balance here the 55
favorite is sam sevien and that comes in both
the longest time control it says four and a half
three enough prediction in his favor and the five
plus one he is expected to go down a game in the
three plus one but then win the bullet by one
so that's like as back a fourth matchup as you
could ask for they are very evenly matched as
indicated by their blitz and bullet ratings
uh they both play a lot on chess.com uh they're
they're blitz and bullet veterans so there's going
to be no sort of experience gap there uh and
we'll definitely keep an eye on uh the smarter
chess predictions as the match uh goes along
but first uh robert uh very important tournament
that's coming up oh yeah and it's not it's kind
of tomorrow i'm losing track of the days here but
tomorrow is the speed chess super swiss fifteen
thousand dollars in prize money i'm sure there
will be many super grandmasters taking part and
it's for an opportunity to qualify for the speed
chess championship so the players in this field
and the jscc as we take a look at the overall
bracket they have an opportunity to qualify
directly the person whose face and name goes
underneath that trophy down there who wins
this jsc bracket they will make their way to
the speed chess championship but other players
will have a chance by participating in the super
swiss this weekend and done as we do look at this
bracket we see that with our final quarter-final
match-up sam savion and alexis serrano if you're
jeffrey zhang who would you prefer to face
nobody i would prefer i would prefer to be karpov
when he faced fisher uh i mean i think that he
probably has a preference on the basis of who he
faced more over the border who he knows better i
guess maybe he faced sebby and more times over the
board he knows him a little bit better but alexis
serrano is is a household name at this point he is
of course russian but he's played across the globe
he's you know he played recently in st louis so
i'm sure jeffrey is familiar with both of them
um and they have somewhat different styles i
think what makes this match really interesting
uh is the fact that sevien and serrano i i know
them pretty well both of them and they have
divergent sort of styles and approaches to the
game uh which we'll talk about and i think that
will produce some very interesting chess yeah
for sure and they're both super tough so when we
ask who would jeffrey rather play it's kind
of like oh who is the weaker player actually
i think as far as our matchups go this is a pretty
good toss-up because if i'm remembering correctly
sevien is around 2660 and serrano around the
same i actually don't know who's the high rate
the two in terms of classical feed a ratings
but this is a tough matchup no matter who goes
on to the semifinals and jeffrey he looked
great he has looked great so far in the jscc
but his opponent going forward will also be a
great player and we do have liftoff down yet
we do and as you said this match is bound to be
about form uh both of these players it really is
a toss-up uh so a lot will be determined in the
early going here in the five minute one thing to
note lexi serrano is famous in russia among
the juniors as an opening specialist he has
incredible opening preparation he is a specialist
in using computers uh to find novelties and i
heard all of this from sort of the top russian
commentator grandmaster sergey shipov who
uh regularly sings serrano's phrases so for sebby
and robert it's going to be very important to
stick to what he knows and uh to spend some
time in the opening not get into any trouble
particularly with the black pieces as we see in
english here in the first game right and with the
white pieces we expect that you know he he should
be able to get a slight pull that's what these
highly rated grandmasters usually do when they
have the first move advantage and right now
his knight and a4 looks a bit awkward but it did
drive this bishop back to a passive square in e7
so that's the good news and that's why cevi
and i almost called him konovets because i
know his username so well he drops his
knight back to c3 saying my job has
been done and white has more advanced pawns on the
you know in the center over here so what do you
make of this dynamic and how are the players going
to push forward from here yeah this is a very
interesting position it has overtones of a sort of
old indian structure uh which is of course kind of
like the king's indian where the bishop coast
goes to e7 i think by and large sir surinaz has
solved most of his opening problems i i think one
idea for to go rookie a bishop f8 and uh to retool
his pieces that way it's important not to take
on e4 uh prematurely because then black exposes
the weakness on d6 so white does have the space
advantage sevien could deploy his other bishop
to b2 or to e3 and he decides instead to lock up
the center interesting and we see a lot of tension
here in the center the winner of this central
tension i think is going to be the one who gets
the clear advantage here as they transition into
the middle game robert yes and it's important
that neither player has captured just yet because
when you do capture something you want to make
certain that it benefits you in some way and look
at this tension remain on the c6 and d5 squares
and now it's all about the queen trade do you
take on b6 which gives black double pawns but
you are capturing towards the center or
do you play bishop e3 so he does take
and he plays an e4 so he's playing for central
control yeah daniel we know full well that anytime
you push this pawn to e4 the bishop on g2 looks
a lot less potent putting behind amazing bishop
while you're having a problem with his mission
right here there's only a lot of squares but yeah
h4 bishop h3 uh this definitely does have these
king zindini kind of vibes and it's very easy
to just assume that white is much better because
he has a lot more space i think white is better
um i think because white does a lot more space
i don't think white's advantage is vast and i
think what sarna has to do is finds some way
to contest light's authority in the center
um right i'm not loving though his own bishop
on h5 is kind of out of play robert i mean f5
always opens up white's bishop not to mention it's
currently just not possible because of e takes f5
rook takes f5 and then g4 so this is unpleasant
stuff here for serrano i'm with you you know i was
focusing on how e4 limits the scope of white's
bishop on g2 but the as you're mentioning the
bishop on h5 which likely is going back to g6
doesn't look so great either and yes black you
play f6 and move the bishop back somewhere but
even if it goes back on that diagonal it's not
actually doing all that much and another thing
that i really like from sevien's point of view
is that a knight c5 move can be met by b4 so it's
not like this knight can just sit happily on c5 no
no white is going to kick that knight out so rook
8 seems like a good starting point for uh serrano
but i like your move h4 i'd play that right now
because bishop g4 does not take back the diagonal
and then white plays f3 and says get out of here
my bishop's coming to h3 where i'm starting to
pester your knight and your pawn on b6 could
become a target right and instead sam has decided
to play rook c2 which is sort of a multi-purpose
move and now sorana brings this other rook
into the queen side i like the positioning of that
rook on a8 it's sort of clamping down on that file
it's it's immobilizing white and here comes h4
now bishop h3 is even more potent uh because it
pins the knight to the rook so serious problems
continue uh to be posed here by set by by sam
yeah just not a comfortable position to play
for serrano he does play knight to c5 so i
was mentioning that b4 can be played but i don't
think he'll play it right now because b4 you have
to capture what happens with knight to d3 the
knight's jumping in it looks like it's wandered
too far and could even maybe get trapped there
but the problem is and i'll just put this on
the board is like oh he plays bishop h3 but if b4
some kind of knight d3 maybe i'll play c5 and get
my knight back to b4 so it's not so so easy for
white to continue and to contain that knight on d3
but if the rook comes to c7 then if we play
b4 knight t3 we can take on b6 and guess what
it's not about the pawn the rook is simply trapped
so sorana goes rook v8 precisely because of that
not a move that you play uh you know easily you
play this move with a heavy heart now savion could
consider taking on c6 and then running that
pawn to b5 and trying to weaken the d5 square
i don't love that strategy because that makes
a lot of concessions it lets blacks knight as
you said occupy that nasty d3 square so i'm
not sure about that maybe go rook d2 first
uh but a big decision here as sebian goes
f3 preferring that more measured approach
making these marginal improvements to his position
just because i don't see a good plan for for alexi
here yeah the only plan i can think of is a knight
a4 type of maneuver at some point saying let me
trade off your really good knight or potential the
great knight on c3 as you mentioned this idea of
taking on c6 playing b4 b5 it's standard to give
me the d5 square but if i play knight a4 well then
i'm trading off your knight before it can ever get
to d5 so that's one thing i'm considering bishop
d8 rerouting the bishop to protect the pawn on
b6 is another but black is just more passive here
dania and if i'm white i may consider b3 you're
not making any progress you're not playing knight
a4 you're not trading knights then i'll go king
f2 i'll go king e2 and i'll just perfect my pieces
before you can do much of anything and that is why
serrano plays knight a4 but now if you take on a4
rook a4 i was trying to make a move such as bishop
to d7 where the problem is again that the a2 pawn
hanging is quite now maybe dc and then bishop
d7 because knight takes c3 can be met with bc
oh you're saying in the initial position let
me uh get back here so okay but now again
there should be some there we go i don't
like this as much though because of c5
but it's interesting because white
can play like a4 and say you're never
doing anything on the queensland i can eventually
play b4 and the side that controls the pawn breaks
is often decided with the advantage not always
but very often and so if i play a4 that does
tie my bishop down though to that a4 pawn not
that the bishop has anywhere else to go at this
current moment i'm just thinking that you know if
i play a4 i cannot play b4 unless my bishop stays
defending that pawn yeah i mean it's interesting
that serrano has been played very quickly he's got
two minutes and right about two and a half minutes
remaining uh and and it's one of those cases it's
not like he he doesn't care it's just that he in a
certain sense you know there's nothing that he can
do so he it's easier for him to just shuffle
his pieces around whereas sevien has to time
the moment when he breaks through correctly he's
under a minute now sorana i'm sort of insinuating
that he might want to play f5 uh which complicates
the equation for sure so b4 maybe can even be met
with f5 that's true an f5 as you're saying
most importantly it complicates things and
even if you play f6 a tamer move and then try to
go bishop to e8 to trade off that bishop one d7
what i don't like about f6 is that this king on g1
may work its way to g4 if the bishops get traded
and into the light squares that's something that
i have a long-term vision of and so f5 does look
much more to the point and creates a problem for
white actually f5 now looks great because you
need to take with the rook on f5 so ryan said for
throwing rook to d and below 30 seconds is sevien
it's not a particularly difficult position to
play for white either of course he could shuffle
his pieces around but if serrano drops his rook
back does he want a5 this bishop on b5 can't move
right yeah so he plays that come on how do you
defend the pawn that was missed for sure by sam
that's a big blunder that is a blunder
he's gonna have to drop e4 and go f4 the
fortunes have changed completely look at the time
situation robert two minutes extra on the clock
and he stacks the exchange wow he's actually
exchanged trying to make the claim that black
can't do much of anything and he's right if white
gets a few moves if this king gets to e4 no black
is really stuck and white's king can become active
and help him to an initiative so king h7 played
and but then bishop g5 so every single one of
these moves involves a concession he does bring
his kingdom toward the center i like that exchange
sack but it has to be handled very precisely if
white is to play for a win here i don't even
know if he can i think that black needs to
try some kind of h5 g5 like break open the king
side and the bishop on b5 still cannot move down
here so that's the good news for uh serrano even
though his pieces aren't doing all that much yet
he's up on the clock he has the potential to
play a move like g5 if you played g5 you made
the great point that white pushes through to h5
then can you play g4 but the king of e4 and say
you're not making any progress whatsoever and
if this rook moves away from d8 there's bishop
back to d7 and that could be a bit annoying so he
plays h5 he's i think he's trying to play for a g5
yeah and sam is very good in time pressure i've
noticed this throughout his blitz games he goes
85 very brave breaking through continuing to
break through now if if c takes b4 i guess he
wants to take on v6 with the bishop so toronto
trying to hold things together let's see how
this unfolds three maybe if rook a3 looks good
just keeping that king on e4 in a bit of danger
six is an idea but this is potentially stacking
the bishop creating even especially now i suspect
that's to be four instead yeah and i'm looking
at rook two eight wait there's rook takes f3 here
because the bishop on f6 had an e4 check you devil
i'm just like trying to find really interesting
mating patterns and tactics and that was one of
them we can show that after the game but i don't
even know if that was that great for black because
of those bishop sacrifices you kept talking about
c4 should be considered here by the way on the
same note rook takes rook says d5 sorry and and
then roxy for check okay or even bishop d8 there
i think rook takes b5 might be very strong here
i see your point because the pawns are doubled
in the b file and then black star can scoop
things up and bishop d8 played and i oh right
anyway can you play f4 at some point for white
you have to there's something otherwise there's
some mating over there now because there it goes
there's like some attack potential against that
black king now who's gonna get checkmated now
rook f4 but bishop f6 there's robert i think he
missed that he did but he could still take on that
forward with the rook and play g4 so i'm not sure
if wait but they need to calculate rook takes b5
rook c4 check and then the end game like too much
going on you're gonna be worse for white i think
so rook b5 cb rook c4 check trade
the zero five is interesting g5 hgh4
oh and then you are threatening to to get
into those i think g5 is very strong here
that's a nice way to break the free there but g5
there might even be rook f5 but a gh yeah g5 check
and rook g5 is important now rook h8 and
never get changed rogue change is just great
he had to give a check on g5 first in order to
draw the king away so it doesn't support that
square but now will savion drum up any kind of
counter play against black's king i don't see it
no the king actually is sitting fine on g6 and
you have a lone rook the bishops getting back
into the game but push that pawn to h yeah and
b6 falls ceronic goes back around to take it
sam trying to create counter play but he just
doesn't have enough pieces on the board rook d4
sorana's time management was stella amazing but
wait a minute now that pawn is defended by the
bishop i'm not sure okay well they both so many
pawns h2 i think should just be played at some
point yeah yes just play h2 lexi just needs to
he's going to now wait a second he hasn't played
h2 oh and he lost the seat pawn and now he does
oh bishop before check what the [ __ ] sequence
that's awesome barely got the move off because
of h1 oh came here but no i can't hold rookie one
okay take nd7 first is prudent but rook d1
was a possibility rook d4 sam is so resilient
oh my gosh that g-pawn got really far too it did
but rook g8 and he's gonna pick it off yeah rook
h6 trying to take any well so he's giving himself
a chance so seven is doing all he can to stay in
this game as long as possible and if somehow this
pawn drops from b4 then you're not winning this
game anymore we saw this in yesterday's match
and some of these exchange down positions when
you can't make progress all of a sudden you
blunder your pawn and boom boom goes the dynamite
for sure and look at serrano's doing a ladder
with his rooks oh he pre-moved bishop too bad
pre-move there well yeah i mean it's very very
hard to defend that for a long period of time and
so rana keeping his foot on the gas pedal
fantastic time management that time by alexi yeah
that was a really fun game there and i don't think
if you're seven you can be that upset there's some
first games you lose where you're just really
frustrated and you can even start tilting as
early as after the first game but that felt like a
true battle you know absolutely it had its ups and
downs he extracts the lessons maybe slightly
better time management uh and here we have a
very topical line of the nimzo this looks crazy
but it's very well studied uh i myself am not
up to date but again um sebian has to be careful
going to these topical lines although he himself
let's not underestimate his preparation which
is absolutely stellar as well didn't we see
this in a previous match um we did we did but
i'm trying to put my finger on which one it was
this definitely did this just doesn't look good
for book what if i just go what's the count yeah
fg and opening the rook up at the end of the day
i'm going to win the piece back and black's king
is just going to be a lot more exposed than whites
right and actually fg had the added benefit of
just yeah bringing your rook into the idea i don't
understand why not fg honestly giving you the f5
square your rook could come to f4 that looked much
better but yeah hg i think that's the move that
you're trained to do right since you're getting
into rook h1 maybe he wants but doesn't quite feel
quite as good and what does it say is like your
coaches right when you're a kid and these players
are still quite young but you're coaching you take
towards the center you take with the h-pawn but
we know that when you're under attack you often
take away from the senator to open up your rook
for not just an aggressive plan but for a line of
defense so now knight capture on e5 down that you
could take on b4 but i'm guessing the f3 square in
particular knight g4 coming with queen x2 threats
wouldn't it be great robert if there was a rook
on f1 that was perhaps controlling the f3 square
oh and if the queen on c2 were protecting and
that would that was not a possibility was it
um acting like a good russian school boy
but maybe a little bit too dogmatically and
by the way i just wanted to put that out
there technically i think it's pronounced uh
saranac with the accent on the last a okay
but that's hard to say so i'm just gonna
keep saying sorana it's a bit of an unusual
last name no no you i i always prefer being
accurate with the pronunciation so sarana
is what we're gonna say it's not as unusual
as people may think in it's similar to the
russian word saran chap which means locust so
well he is fun fact he's trying to plague sevien's
chances of making the speech his champion oh man
you are that was high level i'm just you know
donya i'm just letting you know that i'm here
we're our partners in crime in this commentator
team so i am just trying to i'm trying to play
ball no you are playing ball speaking of which
uh we still need to play ball at some point
true i need to beat you of course uh anyways
now knight f3 knight h4 is a perpetual i think
wow yeah because if okay i'll show that knight
f3 check king has to go to g2 knight h4 check
if you ever take then i have queen g4 queen h4
queen g4 etcetera right your king goes back and
forth my queen does the same this uh song and
dance ends in a repetition right now savion
definitely sees it he has it in his pocket in
these situations you know why do i feel like i'm
sort of unintentionally i was thinking you
sounded like gary even though you weren't trying
these situations you want to you know think take
all of your time you know and try to know think
about you know how you want to play for a win
maybe but i think yeah you do take all of your
time there's no reason not to because there's
white literally cannot avoid the repetition
rook c8 should be considered you could even
take on e6 but there white goes bishop b4
and there's knight g4 ideas as well robert
i really i mean maybe fe i guess bishop b2
but that looks a little bit scary as well but
you're right then after f takes e6 you should
play bishop e2 because that takes away f3 from
the knight but also g4 while of course attacking
the queen on h5 so that would be good and then the
problem for black is well end games are worse for
you your pawn structure is shattered so that's
the potential downside of playing on is that
you have a risk in the long term whereas you have
the short term initiative so i think seven's doing
the right thing here he's spending a good chunk
of time and i get the feeling yeah he'll play
knight f3 in it's pretty good okay and i think
that what were you saying about uh your feeling
yeah this is exactly what i thought was gonna
happen oh yeah well i mean i think you're
trained as a tournament player uh when you're
playing these gm tournaments you're usually fine
with the draw with black and we saw that sevien
got an advantage out of the opening with whites
there's no reason at this point in the match to
go wild um and to do something you know imprudent
he's on the board he gets the white pieces and we
see here another english we do indeed and uh just
wanted to give a shout out to all our viewers
you know it's early in this match we still have
well over an hour of the longest time
control left but i just want to say hey
welcome back if you're you've been watching the
jcc if you're new hey hope you're enjoying it
and keep on watching so we have dania
the same exact line who do you think
in the future will change it up first and say
i'm not playing this exact english line anymore
i know that sevien has been playing english a lot
in in recent months and years i mean right now
the ball is squarely in alexis core because
he got a passive position in the first game
i think that we're going to see less total change
of openings and more modifications so sevien might
change the line of the english that he plays
such as four maybe four e3 or a3 and alexi might
deviate let's say from knight to d4 um knowing
these players are very principled so i think we're
going to see in opening variation rather than
total change of openings that's just you know that
i'm just going from instincts here of course we
could see a lot of different things again i like
white's position here i think the central tension
we might have seen this exact position queen b3
was played in a position like this i mean it just
seems to me that it's harder to play for black
i'm with you and the other game actually the queen
went to b3 before black one queen b6 and then sam
traded there so slight difference but i'm based
on your major point there is i i would agree with
you we saw jeffrey john play d4 and then play e4
he changed his opening on the very first move and
arjun his opponent you know played some karakon
lines and then ended up playing the french so
those are some big changes whereas you're saying
we won't see that kind of switcheroo we'll see
a modification so on move five instead of on move
one also because serana uh is a night or expert he
plays essentially exclusively the night or against
one e4 which is partially why cevian i think is uh
not going into that uh opening because
he is an e4 player um he wants to avoid
uh serrano's preparation in the night or and
against d4 i think alexi also plays uh sort
of almost exclusively to the sloth so it really
depends on who these players are in tournament
chess as well you know with jeffrey he plays a lot
of different stuff even in tournaments and that
obviously reflects on uh players choice in in the
speedchest championship for sure and danny i want
to make one point about this game that's different
from the first is well now black has taken on b3
so that's a big difference black was one of
the double pawns now it's white but also this
rook came to c8 from the uh king side rather
than the queenside rook and that's because
sarana led with queen to b6 and that's important
and just to go back a couple moves here as if
uh sevian had taken on b6 now that rook is already
on a8 where it's meant to be and the rook is on
the c file whereas in the first game he brought
rook a to c8 and had to bring his work back to a8
and then bring his rook from f8 to c8 so it took
unnecessary time so serena actually has made an
improvement i would say over that first game
he takes on d5 he is not afraid of e takes d5
because we have an asymmetrical pawn structure
in that case and after e takes d5 maybe the
bishop gets the g6 and there's even bishop
c2 on the docket going for the b3 pawn
um that was very incisive explanation but i
need to share with you a joke okay go for it
uh how does alexi grandmaster alexi preserve
uh his food for long periods of time
he uses the serrano wrap you know i was hoping
you would make a serrano like reference instead oh
okay that would have been a different way
but i i keep close to the actual names
wait how is that that is the you
know but saran and havana like you're
replacing arbitrarily replacing a word with
another word that deviates from it entirely
i'm just just letting you know that look if that
was a contest i would say ran away with it i would
have ran away with it a long time ago nope nope
we're not letting that happen anyway dania talk
to us about the chest the bishop's on h3 now
it is and here's the issue uh if black plays g6
white can consider going f3 and literally just
going after that bishop on h5 threatening g4
if alexi goes well he goes rook f8 but here's the
problem now that rook is tied down to the pawn and
sevien could consider going either b4 or rook f
to c1 to prepare before so he's basically playing
on both fronts um and black's resources are
stretched uh very thin much like so will uh alexis
actually be able to keep everything together
i think so because b4 robert has a downside
b4 rook ac8 and white might have a hard time
keeping that c4 pawn defended because if b3
then you could play b5 trying to exploit that
newly undefended knight on c3 so again we saw
in the first game sembian take a lot of time in a
moment like this and again uh saranac is up a lot
of time on the clock f4 very interesting move he
continues to operate on the king's side uh do you
agree with that comment that actually employee of
the month because i have to put up with your jokes
but actually what you were saying was really
important because b4 c5 that's a typical idea
uh in a position of this nature but you have
to watch out for the c4 point typically your
bishop is not on h3 your bishop is somewhere
defending that pawn so you feel free to move the
pawn to b4 so this has the vibes of a sicilian
right where you took on d5 at some point and
white took back with e pawn and tries to go for
the queenside palm majority and i like black's
position because the bishop on h5 may look
a bit awkward but now this pawn is on f4 and
cannot go to f3 to try to trap the bishop that's
an annoying bishop that at some point can even get
into a square like e2 and put some pressure on
the c4 pawn i do see what you're saying i agree
i also like the way that sevien has handled this
placing that rook on c1 to lend reinforcement to
the knight on c3 now if rook c8 he can very
freely play beat well it's happened i guess
let's see what uh sarna has cooked up here maybe
bishop d a bishop b6 that's a pretty typical idea
instead he goes rook c7 what he has to watch
out for robert is that c5 breakthrough which
can come even if uh that means sacrificing a
pawn sometimes c5 followed by d6 can happen
i'm not saying here but serrano's just preparing
b5 here that's actually surprisingly hard to deal
with the knight on c3 is still very loose maybe
7 goes b5 but that in turn yields the c5 square
right and honestly i was looking at f takes e5
because if you take with the knight there could
be some bishop b6 but the problem is look
at these light squares that knight is about
to jump into it can just give you an immediate
force so that doesn't quite pan out for white
i imagine and he plays bishop to g2 first covering
the f3 square and the bishop wasn't doing anything
on h3 or staring into a pawn that was defended so
there's a lot of tension here and at b5 which is
your idea well i can also can i consider taking
it like i'll give you my knight and then get a
pass pawn on a6 that's a very deep idea actually
that's a very deep idea because you have that
pawn on a6 in the end right so if i you know trade
you here and then take on uh take on a6 now i have
these runners on the queen side oh crap i
got the memo and don't compliment robert
keep forgetting yeah that is a nice move hey
well you know me donna i'm happy to sacrifice
other people's pieces and absolutely the b5 plan
that you've been highlighting for a long time i've
been thinking about it while you're talking about
other things i'm just considering how am i going
to react to that and if i do play c5 i'm not sure
i get oh um okay that all sort of perfect sense
it does now the question is can alexia
now turn up the knob on the pressure
i consider breathing the sacrifice
on c4 i don't think it is warranted
because when the c file opens white could
land a rook on c7 with disastrous effect
so for example bcbc let's say you take on c4
twice white has to move knight a2 at the end
so sarnath plays bishop f6 he does find a way to
increase that pressure on the knight on c3 but now
robert c5 and d6 has to be considered um sort of
even more carefully because that pawn on d6 will
be undefended by a bishop that used to be on e7
and he does play c5 it's a great point that you've
allowed me to push to d6 so you guys go for it and
c6 only move uh-oh and knight c5 there's knight d5
right wheels start coming off tactics everywhere
and there could be a four oh and there's also
knight b4 like knight c5 knight d5 i'm hitting
your bishop i'm threatening to even take on c5 and
play d7 in some ways i'm very knight to b4 to kick
your rook from the defense of the knight this is
just winning honestly it is the only thing is the
time situation so we're not trying to complicate
things but he definitely underestimated
the power of a knight that lands on d5
so can you can you get away with this it just
doesn't look like it i mean this knight d5
is so obvious i mean i don't see what else you
can do i mean you can go bishop f3 but that
is a very temporary bulwark against with the
pressure me white could go b4 king f2 i mean that
that's not a sustainable defense is there a
difference if you throw an ef4 so that the
h4 pawn is hanging so that's a big difference
because in these lines of knight to d5 maybe i
will have some kind of bishop takes h4 which not
only attacks the rook and traps it but defends the
d8 square in case you push okay i just saw the
evaluation bar just so that was about oh whoa
that i did not see that no very good what if i
take it and play bishop d4 and then right yeah
he said it's all about that one pass fun
and then rookie seven no that's a crushing
idea i think robert yeah because you're
rookie a check first even and then it just
okay that's a good i mean i could see a case being
made for that because now c6 is a devastating
threat right so c6 is devastating you can okay
somebody before exactly you walked into the fort
and serrano realizes that you can tell by that
pause yeah it's over and i can't tell if he's in
hot water because of the game or because the sauna
that seems to be in his background but either way
you know here we see that white is up a piece
and trading off is not going to help down goes
a6 bishop d6 first you take on a6 you're going to
take on b5 in the second and your b pawn will grow
yeah and uh the technique and i've been impressed
throughout the jscc matches by the technique uh
conversion technique of these players which
is sort of traditionally something that you
know young players sometimes struggle with
but uh not in this tournament their their
technique their positional understanding
has been superb throughout with that being
said right three seconds he's got to demonstrate
some precision here as the king has made its way
to b5 a commanding blockading goes out g5 yeah
what about g5 oh whoa whoa whoa then bishop e7
bishop c3 but is this winning because the pawns
this is not going to be easy by the way f4 and
black just stays put if the game takes on g5 then
the pawn rushes to f2 and distracts the bishop
yeah you're right and you're just
complimenting the technique so you oh
wait the evaluation bar just what did you oh wait
it's yourself oh it's king d5 no king d5 was the
wrong way b5 is okay we need to draw let's look
at their faces because unbelievable oh my gosh
miraculous wait was i missing anything roberto
king b5 is just a draw it was i'm going to bring
up that analysis board because oh my lands
disbelief by saranac there he just like what
happened and we're getting a repeat of the opening
so let's bring up quickly that position because
king d5 was a major mistake he was bringing his
king closer to his pawns but he needed to stay
attached to the b4 pawn if king f5 you'd point
this out dania that you just jettison this pawn
and you win the b4 pawn and that's a draw king and
bishop cannot checkmate king so that was a missed
opportunity just one more time back here he went
to d5 no no because his king wasn't attached to
this pawn so in that sequence just to finish that
off now i can just take bring my bishop back and
win with my past pawn so an unfortunate series
of events there for sarana we get back to the
live position and whoa we had a repeat of the line
and something has changed here he hasn't taken acg
but again this looks very very dubious for black
well he took on d7 first the last time he took on
c3 and then there was a b c f g or something
like that and then he took with the h here he
took on d7 first and now this has changed where
black doesn't have that knight coming to e5 so
what is this line the evaluation bar i see it off
to the side here it says it's in black's favor
i don't imagine that trading queens could
ever be good for black because they just
trade and then take on b4 so that leaves team
g7 rook h8 and checkmate down the h5 i mean
i still don't understand why white didn't play
fg uh earlier i mean it seems like he's setting
himself up for that attack on the h file clearly
there is a reason for it that you know i just
don't fully understand because i'm not uh
you know knowledgeable enough in this line
after king g7 robert the more i look at this
position initially i thought why is the one
attacking but white is the one making a lot of
noise but as you said once a rook lands on h8
black doesn't need to make a lot of noise
all he can do is just deliver checkmate
yeah well the noise is it's you once you tune it
out and you just let it play itself through it's
like well what what does it actually help you you
stole you would want to put this pump back on h7
whoa e6 what is happening in this something tells
me this is some sorry not home cooking what if i
just take it yeah or not what if you take it i'm
really trying to figure out that that wasn't meant
g6 is an idea to force the free trade but after
queen takes bishop takes bishop takes c3 right
so i don't take the bishop right away i take the
pawn i'm hitting multiple things and i'm going to
take your bishop next move um you want to explain
e6 to me a little more what's the downside of pawn
takes e6 because i still have rook h8 ideas i'm
still attacking your pawn on c3 which is pinned
i think i know what savion is trying to determine
and that is what is the downside of ftx there must
be something because the pawn is on e6 the seventh
rank is over so maybe there's some kind of queen
b2 queen b7 or rook b1 rook b7 where there's like
a problem or exactly is that or it could just be a
bluff but i'm trying to work my way through this
and look at sarana's time he spent eight seconds
for the entire game definitely i don't think it's
a bluff well we're about to find out buckle your
seatbelts oh and look at that so by the way i just
noticed the evaluation bar and went to zeros and
before was like minus one and a half so something
in this line the engine relatively low depth right
i'm just trying to help assist everybody to see
you know can't catch up with our words you can see
on the screen who's better it's caught up now it's
zeros i think queenie two might it might survive
because queen e2 uh if queen takes two knight
takes e2 and very importantly the knight defends
well it doesn't actually defend the c3 pawn but if
bishop takes e3 white doesn't have to waste time
moving his rook he can take the bishop so why
was e6 necessary in that equation oh i see the
big difference if queen e2 the queen takes h7 the
difference is you no longer control the g4 square
and i also have the e5 square available to
me so if i take and you try rook h8 i might
have some queen e5 checks and queen
g4 checks and that may save the day
right i mean i find it hard to believe that this
definitely was not in serrano's preparation e6 was
just a move he kind of threw out there um i think
he is going to find queenie too just by process
of elimination i don't see any other way to even
reach a playable position i think all other moves
you can essentially resign well what about this
one same idea but i mean now i look at the bars as
minus 2.6 so that was not as good of an execution
i think because now queen takes age 7 and rook hay
does look very scary robert but there's still
this g4 square you have to deal with okay but
queen g4 i'll move the king and if you go queen h4
i'll take it and go rook giant and checkmate you
thought you knew a lot to consider
right where's the time mcqueen takes h7
and you know the queen does get to g4
but dania's saying that he's very quick
uh on the h5 which is right totally fair even
in the event of a queen trade uh that king on
g1 is confined it could go rook g8 check down
the open g file drive the king to the h file
and deliver a ladder checkmate so dania there's
not even queen g4 i mean look at this queen h7
c takes b if you go quincy for check first you
go k8 ct before e5 oh that's beautiful and you
just go after the piece yeah i'm going after
the piece and if you take immediately on b4
i have e5 to start with taking away your check
on g4 so the queen on e2 was essential to stop
e5 from being played because now the bishop covers
the diagonal here comes rook h8 if your knight
moves i also have bishop c6 going for checkmate
oh and ooh not a is not a fiber move here
knight f5 who are you i'm dr jenkins can i can
i move my king to g8 it's important to move it
to ga but then queen g4 check and queen d4
ah i see i think so queen g4 check king h8
okay let's let's d4 check so knight f5 check
let's start here right what if i just take on f5
oh you're going to check take and then go queen
d4g yeah exactly right here let's show everybody
here check rook f7 queen d4 you get the bishop
back and now white's i'm going to be frank here
i think alexi is just not spending enough time
evaluating the tactical subtleties he's just
you know he's making these tempting moves
but and he's he's sort of relying on
uh savion's doubt in the fact that it's as clear
as it seems to be but sevien is is is confident in
himself he is going to call uh sorana's bluff and
this is going to backfire there is enough time in
the five minute portion to do that so i'm really
not a big fan right now of the strategy of playing
really fast and you know not really doing a lot
of calculation i think this is really really bad
for white i'm with you donna and i think that in
these type of variations because some people like
hey can you show me the sharpest lines i want to
checkmate my opponent but in these super sharp
lines there are situations where if you make one
inaccuracy not even a blunder right it's not like
saranac blundered a piece no no he just missed
an idea he's still up upon the position but as we
see to the left of the screen here he's busted
and so that's the problem with playing these
really sharp lines is you could just fall apart
instantly whereas if you play a closed position
where you're slightly worse yeah you'll suffer
but you may not have the same risk of just
having the game end in a couple turns so that's
just a trade-off i would say stylistically sarana
is a very aggressive player and he plays sharp
long theoretical lines we saw him do that against
magnus carlsen in the isle of man where he went
into this end game from a sicilian and tried to
outplay magnus from there the game ended in the
draw but here it is clearly backfired yeah i mean
even the most well-prepared players it's easy
to confuse and forget stuff given the amount of
just uh amount of variations and openings that
uh any professional player has to keep in his
mind especially a professional player who has a
repertoire as topical and sharp uh as alexi does
so it's understandable uh but i agree i think he
needs to modify his opening approach slightly um
and you know if he's a d4 player he's going
to continue playing d4 but maybe going into a
somewhat less sharp line i'm sure he has something
in reserve as he dips below a minute here he's
just not finding anything and i don't think
anything exists there's just too many threats
against white's king and against that open
h file yeah it's fine like knight f3 to
bring your knight to h4 to close things down
there's bishop g4 right just pin the knight and
i guess bishop g4 knight g5 was something i was
considering oh my gosh you're a frustrating oh
but there's an amazing idea okay bishop g4
probably doesn't work yeah knight g5 yep and
now it definitely doesn't work i was going to take
on d1 uh-huh and knight takes f uh knight takes h7
i was going to go bishop f3 yeah it doesn't work
according to this it doesn't work because it's
knight but if you take the rook i just wanted to
show that rook takes f8 there is no way to stop
the idea of rook h8 rook h1 as slow as it is i
don't think there's any way to stop that but it
doesn't work oh well we actually are seeing
this variation so knight g5 was played yeah
but i wouldn't take the queen here i would not
move the queen queen h5 but then a6 oh my gosh
you're just the most important f6 i would just do
that and go king f6 and win the night but you're
finding all these tactical resources but you're
right 96 just king f6 and what if f3 here f3 i
think i could just take your knight i take yours
your bishop queen e3 check and queen e4 check
and like rooksy i don't know there must be some
kind of mate yeah but but then i have queen d7
yeah i think f6 is important here so king f6 is
good if i run to the corner you may have queen d7
stuff right it's hard to play down on the
clock and he's down below 20 seconds here
that is the danger of dipping so far down
in the clock he does go king f6 and there's
going to be bishop e6 like f4 so he's very
careful yeah f4 that's because the bishop
that's a great move there king comes to g6
you have f5 under control yeah five in rook
81 robert this is not over i definitely
don't think it's over but at least he has
found a way to make his king feel safer for
the time being the king can slide back to h7
d7 is under your control no he plays rookie six
trading off pieces solid as a rock but now if he
trades and simply goes rook yeah rook c1 king
is not out of the woods well neither king is
obviously oh i don't like queen h5 it just feels
like you're walking away from your king here
queen f5 played steals b7 uh-oh now bishop
d5 though rookie six and he defends against
the checks now white's king is the one who's
going to come under fire gta play quincy a oh
yeah he's too many threats here now f5 and but
it's over yes on time what a crazy game that was
indeed almost worked his way out of that position
he went wrong somewhere you know his you want to
stray from what the variations should look like
and it did get crazy but credit to samsevian he
held it together he did and king found king f6
he took uh a good amount of time but he trusted
himself you know it's very easy to say well of
course he found these these simple moves but you
know when you're in the heat of the moment you're
facing someone who is known as a theoretician as
someone who uh you know knows what he's doing in
the opening it's very easy to doubt yourself and
somebody who is able to remain confident as sevien
did deserves uh praise just for that as we see um
i guess i i stand corrected we see another repeat
of the same exact line yeah you know we're only
moving 13 so it's you know not a big deal they've
just repeating the same line that's a huge deal
okay it's a huge deal robert that's all we want to
talk about oh queen a4 no more queen b3 business
okay so there's pressure on the c6 pawn now and
does sarah not take on d5 or does he protect the c
pawn well i like the idea of taking because white
can't really take with a knight that e2 pawn is
going to fall um but maybe cd white does have
g4 he does decide to keep the tension though
and again we see e4 which is a move we kind of
discussed previously but it's a bit of a different
iteration here with the queen being on a4 it adds
different kind of dynamic to the position and it
does prevent knight to d7 we've seen that idea
played in both games thus far the queen air force
says yeah you can't get there so he's thinking
right now and is there some sort of g4 probably
not because there's d4 for black and that actually
and rook takes c4 as well so that's not even a
possibility i guess so what is he considering
just trying to figure out which one to take
yeah but cdc i was going to say what i like
here for black there's queen d4 as an idea
there is there's many ideas here you can play a6
and then drop the queen back and go for b5 he does
that i like that um bishop robin's white bishop is
tied down exactly guys about to say bishop e3 is
the movie you want to play we need to be two pawns
hanging i would go queen a3 and get that bishop
out queen e3 is a really good move because i think
when you look at the b2 pawn a lot of people say
queen c2 towards the center but you're walking
right into a pin not the biggest deal in the
world but can be annoying so queen a3 defends the
b2 pawn although it does allow him like queen c5
in black can try to trade queens right that
is true um but with that if there's rook b1
which is a blunder to do rook takes c3 that's
important to point out and he does go queen a3
you need circulation among your ranks here if
you have an entire side of the board that's
it's not moving uh that's not going to bode well
given that black has most of his resources on
the queen side we see now this very interesting
maneuvering battle who is going to prevail on
the queen side is black going to manage to get b7
b5 in or is white going to coordinate along the c
file and uh black has some holes there
bishop e3 knight a4 and ip6 comes to mind
either side could prevail on that flank
robber yeah knight d7 is bringing another
piece from the king side over to the center
and eventually the queen side so the 97 is fine
this bishop on h5 it continues to be an
issue and white as per usual can play pawn to
h4 and try to improve the location of
the bishop coming to h3 so that's likely
something we're going to see in this game right
now indeed and for black he could consider b5 but
that entails its own calculus knight c5 very again
very typical placement and again we see this does
white play b4 um before knight d3 might there
might be rook cd1 and that knight might be trapped
so actually i would very seriously consider it
before here right and i'm just showing that uh
evaluation the variation through to its conclusion
the knight gets trapped so even though you took a
rook for just a bishop the knight goes down as
well and i get two minor pieces for my rook but
after b4 black goes knight back to d7 and look at
that c4 square the knight could redirect itself
over on over to b6 and then to c4 so pawns do
not go backwards as um you know the great marcus
rally is the roman philosophers talked
about and um i guess evian realizes that but
we'll see well for sarana it's pretty easy knight
d3 gets trapped because of rook c to d1 so then
you have to go knight to d7 and he is thinking at
this point so oh okay so what is it cd1 doesn't
work somehow but why why does something look oh
no i mean look at the barge i'm i am oh the bar
yeah it works maybe it's time for that night to go
to the bar true yeah or alexis yeah i wonder what
he was thinking though because he plays knight
d3 he just means he honestly must have just
thought that rook d1 was impossible because
the bishops on h5 just overlooked it he thought
rook c2 was forced and then black has a5 and you
know the pawns come to the rescue of the knight
you can just see well it's not over let's be very
clear knight takes f2 white has we have to put
things in perspective your white has two pieces
for a rook now savion is actually considering
taking the knight amazingly that also attacks
on it but there's no need for uh those kinds
of gymnastics and if i were alexi yeah he gives up
the knight for a pawn i would try to put things in
perspective here and say okay i've got a rook for
two pieces i've got that c4 square now for my rook
white has a very difficult technical task ahead of
him agreed it's not going to be a straightforward
win for white but clearly savion's position is
much better but b5 is a good start you can get
rooks to c4 to double your rooks at some point you
may play a5 to b4 but if you ever push this a pawn
the b5 it's not just for the pawns with the
squares on the queen side and that's why bishop
came back i like that one here bishop g5 let's
trade bishops and the d6 pawn becomes weaker
but looser protection of the queens and squares
on white's end as well yeah and if you take on
g5 and try to play a4 to sort of make inroads on
the queen side you have to watch the move a5 in
general because that knight on c3 is somewhat
undefended only the queen is defending it and
uh sebian needs to keep an eye on that knight so
i just off the top of my head i'm not exactly sure
what the most prudent way of sort of making
inroads is maybe you want to take on g5 and
go knight e1 and just redirect that knight over to
d2 and then b3 but that does seem a little bit too
slow another idea i would say is you know i don't
want to allow you to take me on e3 that's clear
to me so if i take on g5 queen g5 and then play
bishop to d3 that way i can put my knight on e
tabasco sauce right there but is that going to
backfire that was not what i was expecting because
he's voluntarily making his king a bit weaker but
gaining some space and he's saying i have the two
minor pieces i can do this my king is not going
to be attacked by what a lone queen right so fast
i don't like it i don't know i don't like it
at all i mean what if i take on a fourth queen
i guess 92 but then rook c4 i mean it's just white
is not able and i think he realizes it now you
can tell always by the pause in between moves
that are somewhat forced he's thinking oh man
i didn't evaluate this probably queen h492 rook
c4 the position to collapse in two moves there is
queen to b1 so it's not totally collapsing but it
looks not very good so but even dinosaur queen h4
92 this is protecting the rook uh and the
knight's coming to defend the g3 square rook
c4 i think queen b1 to defend the pawn and the
rook and if corrupted c4 don't like bishop f2
oh yeah you do right i think we need seven oh
your queen is coming back so i don't even have
bishop f2 so what's going on here this is i guess
i take you take and now we have a whole new new
game look at what he's done he has given i like
what he's done he's given up at four but at least
he keeps his pieces uh close to the chest
at least he's not going to lose any of them
but now it's two pawns and a rook for the
two-minute pieces and white has the worst king so
knight comes to d4 that's looking at the c6 square
and that's going to be a huge pain for black to
deal with but then maybe black can say let me go
rook e8 and focus in the center rather than the
queen side that's a great idea just ignore the c6
square all together focus on building your assets
serenado's bishop before activating the bishop
taking the e5 square under even further control
now the knight could go to f5 but
i'm not sure it will be stable there
on account of g6 i'm not sure black would want
to go g6 immediately for now fighting his time
is seven with queen b3 but now you've got to
watch for bishop d2 and rook c3 ideas true and
i was just looking at bishop h2j excuse me but
king g2 keeps this bishop safe and sound but
coming up with different ideas here trying to
infiltrate with the pieces bishop d2 looks good
and followed by rook c3 i like that idea uh what
else can you play here rook this rook doesn't
exactly have another square on the c file to
work with because we play rook c7 then knight c6
makes you work on cc yeah this idea of knight c6 i
think raises the urgency and he does go bishop d2
so c3 is going to be unpleasant well which
uh score do you go to e2 or d1 with this rook
well wherever you go you need
to make a decision right now
yeah he plays it you're not threatening rook takes
d2 because of queen g5 good call very good vision
there so that's not a threat so rook c3 does still
work out you could always throw in queens if i
check if you need it he plays rook c3 and now wait
wait bishop e3 might be good because you can't
take my rook because i have queen takes up two
check and i'm just trying to remove one of your
very important defenders of your king aha i
really like that call maybe knight f5 then
trying to throw that blanket over oh it's getting
live there's a discovery a possibility there if
the knight moves so if the bishop moves away from
e3 rook g3 is going to be a threat i mean this is
so hard to play for white though and he does go
bishop bishop c5 is kind of a nasty move right
threatening rook g3 and you cannot move the
king anywhere maybe you go bishop g2 there
covering the king as best you can watch
out for rook g3 oh bishop g2 there might be
there's some three d3 yeah this is getting complex
so what if what if i just take and play rook
to c8 like can i just do that and go after the
dark scores later i completely agree you could
go rook see it even immediately but i i don't
see any particular reason to keep the tension
and i guess one move for white is knight to
d4 next just to keep the bishops on whoa that
was played and bishop takes c5 oh wait there's
some problems with the dark squares there are
he's just created some big wheat i would go king
faith then bishop g to rook f1 maybe uh-oh queen
yeah that's not the end of the world though
king h-a because white's own king is also
very weak this is going to be a time scramble
buckle up okay so queen d4 check and then f6
and then rook d2 rook f2 okay he goes bishop
g2 to go rook up one he doubles but rook of
one is rookie c1 very importantly very important
move trading off the rooks at the last second he
takes now black is better again age five well
what's up queen e7 check watch out for that
check stop saying oh good vision there queen
g5 is possible queen might just be winning but
then there's take take knight f3 you have to
calculate the e5 pawn break the queen rook c2
wait for queen a7 and knight g4 oh
g4 what a scene runs where's the h
h5 coming no but we're not six of spades
okay okay he he had h5 at some point but
now rooks he won oh oh that's a buzz
kill yeah that's everything for lapses
what a game yeah we're like it's also saying
the same thing today it's worrying me yeah
somehow we're on the same page that's not good
robert we need to we really need to change oh my
gosh what a crazy game that was absolutely i mean
that was just they had all of the ingredients of
high-level the kind of high-level chess that we've
been seeing day in and day out at the jfcc and
we have to acknowledge it serrano blundered he
put his knight on d3 he missed rook c to d1 but
he kept his composure and that's really important
because the game is not won or lost often at the
first mistake it's what happens as you get into
time trouble as the game continues so we have a
two and a half two and a half start after five
games sarana has the white pieces and speaking
of sharp chest dania these kind of anti-moscows
what to what to take about this it it is um
it's it's a crazy together with a bottleneck
which we saw once yesterday this is what i would
consider to be the sister uh or the cousin or
choose your relative of the batmanic where black
does cling to that pawn on c4 but it doesn't take
um a long time to see that white's got a lot of
compensation in the form of central control in
the form of the fact that black i mean black's
position could collapse very very easily here
there's a lot of peace sacrifices uh kind of the
style of the king's gambit actually where you just
leave your knight on c3 well he has now he hasn't
sacked the piece because he takes on f6 but black
has to handle this very precisely black's king
for the time being is stranded in the center so
if there are files that open such as the b file
the attack could come very very fast and i see
that the bar is going up in white's favor super
complex variation i would take on h8 and take on
a1 and then c4 is probably going to fall and even
if black castle's long because that before it's
what i mentioned because that b file has opened
black's king just does not have any safe place
to go to but alexi chooses rook b1 yeah he has
book h6 bishop g5 with tempo keeping the king
stuck in the center and he will regain this
pawn on b2 so that's his claim c4 will also
fall you made a mention of that so what's the
current material count black has all eight pawns
even though they're scrambled across the board
white has six pawns two extra pawns for
black but once b2 and c4 fall that's
restores material quality and black's king is in
worse shape white's king on g1 is safe and sound
for the time being but dinah there are sometimes
these ideas where black plays move like g3 to
open up the king on g1 something to consider
is while the king looks safe for now you have
pushed your pawn to h4 and that has some
drawbacks as well yeah that's a great point
wherever there is a pawn like that you know
white has to keep an eye on it now here's a
thought after rook h6 bishop bishop g5 could black
try c3 i realize it looks completely unsustainable
but if you take that rook on h6 notice that
black's bishop can then swing over to d2
and defend c3 so i don't believe in that but i i
think that sevien needs to be very concerned here
because despite the two extra pawns he's going to
lose one of them um so i would consider a c3 here
almost as a desperate measure but the problem is
serrano could go queen b3 he doesn't even have to
take the rook yeah i was saying queen d3 as well
just to get this pawn back he plays queen b3 which
is better i was looking at queen takes d4 but i
forgot the bishop mb7 would be hanging so queen
d3 my idea was that hey i'm still attacking your
pawn and bishop v4 was never possible because the
bishop is needed to defend the brook but same idea
different execution you are losing your pawn on c3
and then down goes b2 after that right right and
then you won't even have a pawn for your suffering
i could see this ending in the next ten moves
that's the downside of these lines for black
robert is is you need to handle them so well
sebian is a slav player he's he he knows the
bot he's a specialist in the batmanic variation
um but alexi made a very good choice by going for
uh this the moscow variation i think it's a little
less familiar that's just heavy than the botany
for sure and look at the time situation by the
way sarana has four minutes and 20 seconds and
sevien down to two minutes he has less time
his position is not very good he also lost
the previous game which could fluster him a bit
and for serrano he's looking to take the lead
once again he had the lead after the first
game of the match then savion stormed back
and now it's sarina these kind of back and forth
the seesaws will happen in such a long match look
at the time situation in the three-minute portion
looking forward it's going to be important for for
sevien to stabilize the ship i mean almost
three minute advantage for sarina and i was
a little bit critical of that strategy uh in the
previous two games ago uh in certain positions but
that is not to say he's not very well prepared and
confident and those things are obviously very good
uh as we can see here he's supremely confident
in these positions and he's playing flawless
game leaving himself with tons of time
for the conversion phase okay a5 is
a good move all things to put the bishop on b4
that's actually it was a really smart it was by
because what do you do now i mean f3 is
an idea too potentially right f4 that's
true f3 is an idea i'm looking at the center
and looking at d4 and e4 i'm like that looks
good but i could see black turning around and
attacking that center and the bishop one before
has stabilized thanks to this pawn on a5 and an
eventual c5 move could be a bit annoying g3 is
possible here but then i could go f4 and ram that
on through to f5 yeah that doesn't look very good
the problem again as we discussed the king
has no safe haven maybe sevilla needs to find
a way to attack that d4 pawn that seems to be
the only tender spot in white's camp but look
at that bishop on g5 not only is it a thorn in
black's throat it's also guarding the d8 square
and he plays c5 he had to right he has to go after
the d4 but i would play d5 i'm not opening this
position up for black's pieces and d5 keeps things
closed and the king on f8 is in the most danger
and if he takes d5 then i was going to probably
take on g4 but i didn't calculate it thoroughly
i just thought the key would be didn't calculate
thoroughly that's unacceptable i calculate every
recommendation of course you do so rook takes
before f takes g4 how do you feel about that
no you have to do that rook takes before
is to kind of move that plate that
your hand just makes that movement man your brain
has to approve of it or there will be rebellion
because we keep talking about the king being
stuck here and if i allow well bishop c5 now is
disastrous because it's a pin and winning the
queen but i just see black coming back if you
just allow some activity and rook to see one that
feels like you're going the wrong direction you're
keeping your extra pawn but you're losing your
attacking chances so i would focus on the attack
rook takes b4 politics for punting g4 opening this
rook up just trying to get after this rook on g6
as well i don't really see how black meets that i
could see a case being made for rook c2 here sort
of i suppose in the style of a computer saying
all right i'm not actually going to give you any
material but i am obviously on board with you what
about the pawn a4 if you like rook c2 yeah and i
was going to go rook c1 there wait takes a 4 rook
c1 but i have queen a3 in those kind of positions
but no i completely agree with you
like even though white's better
we know that it just with the queen's off the
board it gives some better chances for black
i would argue after queen a3 if we
look concretely i would go queen f4
and i know alexi he does it he doubles
on the c poker that i'm not sure about
but yeah look at the the bar
next to the board it went
really down and queen e3 didn't like though no
it hated queen d4 maybe ooh no you didn't queen
h8 is a devastating threat yeah yeah nc6 is also
a threat and the difference is the rooks doubled
here protects c5 he goes queen f4 which is still
going to be good bishop c5 rook takes c5 would
have won tactically because of a check on d6 c6
now and bishop a6 do you just promote the pawn
you just say you know what i i'm a man of
simple taste i'm gonna promote that pawn
that's so painful like you you're trying to stop
the attack which you might not even be successful
in doing and then bishop a6 happens and here comes
c7c and that is uh something that we've referenced
as savion trying to muddy the waters here with
e5 as he should but oh because that rook on g6
now it's all of a sudden attacking c6 so sir has
to be accurate here it takes an e5 there's queens
yeah right you go after the material you
don't always go after checkmate sometimes
you just go after the material when you're
attacking and that can be the most effective
foolproof strategy and here queen c3 forces the
queens off the board because the rook tries to
block kate on c7 there's bishop to d8 so i mean
among other things that should be good enough he
plays queen wait disrupted 466. oh my lance oh
i suggested and of course it's bad he misses it
no but now c7 bishop c7 is his idea there's no
way that i can work no way i mean even what f4
here just push that pawn through then f6 maybe
yeah but now just f g i mean the pieces start
falling apart for for saving because f6 bishop
h5 nice yeah and now bishop f4 i mean anything
is bishop d7 bishop f4 nice yeah this is this is
over yeah but this is one that was a big chance
and it's funny because that discovery
still was in my mind so i was using fg
and icing f4 i was just trying to stop the
bishop checks but he he misses one chance to
stay in the game there now he has 2.7
seconds left there's a passport on c6
he's alive but how is he doing this c6 i don't
understand uh rook takes a four bishop c6 rook c4
okay it's kind of serrano has to be careful
i mean that king on h3 is not entirely safe
but no it's just yeah it's a free piece yeah okay
and i wonder uh for sam if he's looking forward
to the quicker time patrols or if he'd prefer
to play more in the longer one because he's
playing this i mean yeah it's so evenly matched
that i think they both don't necessarily have
a preference in this case uh but yeah maybe
just like inertia so 25 minutes left it's
been you know neck and neck in these games
yeah let's bring up that board yeah from the
last game once more just show that tactic
that was overlooked by uh sevien he was on the
defensive he didn't have much time but things at
this point here the queen trade which i suggested
turns out to be not so good because rook takes c6
rook c6 bishop c6 oxide point is this
is immune because bishop h2 check and
i guess i don't know it's it's still looks good
for white yeah but well yeah of course black is
still worse but comparatively speaking robert
i mean this would be big turn of events and you
might look at it and say well two bishops for a
rook is better but look at that pass upon that's
the whole point right right that does give you a
chance and bishops are obviously on the opposite
color the two bishops and you can't team up on
squares so there could be a way for black to try
and hold it so would be good for white so let's
go back to the current game as hey can i get wait
this is from the english but there's a pawn on
c3 so clearly there's a trait on that square can
i give myself a pat on the back here because you
said four e3 and it happened well i said that's
i said that he would keep the same openings
but change the variation that's what he did
yeah he's playing the sort of carlson way where
you push the pawn e4 and serrano is actually
dealing with this quite well yes because in the
way that white has played this you've given up
some light square control you're still fighting
for the center on the d4 and e5 squares and
right now this is a critical moment because i was
thinking i'm obviously i don't think you want to
take on d4 but maybe tactically there's some kind
of knight before maybe four yeah it also almost
reminds me of a ryan lopez for some reason which
i can't put my finger on uh is it because there's
a pawn on e4 and you just took on d4 and yeah
okay well knight before idea exists also in c5
undertone not that he's going to play it okay so
he does it i'm again the speed with which he goes
for this line because even after a knight before
it's not like when you take on a2 or whatever
oh i don't do this i don't know how to do this
like do i go over k2 first do i play knight to b4
um or nothing or do you go
if rookie eight i don't know
well he decided to move first and
think later he didn't play for d8 okay
that's probably the one e5 then i have
knight d5 like you're giving me something
oh you're gonna check me he's so confident i mean
i to me i would be like i would be terrified here
even queen takes c4 bishop d5 i mean everything
has to be considered i like that where you take
two pieces for the queen and then you threaten
f7 you threaten c6 it probably doesn't pan out
take one page out of your book sacrificing others
i'm into it let's just look at it we're analyzing
queen c4 bc4 bishop takes d5 and i'm you know
who doesn't like it uh mr grandmaster bar yeah
master bar mr barr is not a fan of the sacrifice
it looks good to me just by good i mean it looks
pretty cool but i guess you could probably
just even take on e5 or something like that
right then bishop c6 pawn d4 i don't know it's
too much to calculate starting to look good
for black though yeah no it's too little stuff
now 94 is a far more measured and prudent move
look at those dark squares i mean those dark
squares are going to be in alexis nightmares
they certainly will and knight speak well there's
not going to be four queen d2 and queen h6 you're
just so focused on the checkmate give me a break
so what about rook takes a2 now and i take with
the knight on a2 and at least i hit your bishop
on c1 i don't care i'm gonna go queen h6 anyway
you take my rook on a1 you knock yourself out
no but then knight g5 will attack my queen
that's what i'm trying to do you you uh started it
with the queen sack i'm returning the fear we're
going to look at this line very quickly rook takes
knight takes queen h6 so he's going to take on c1
you're going to go knight g5 to try to checkmate
me on h7 i was going to throw in a check on you
too and then probably sacrifice my question just
just so you know but i don't even know if it works
no i definitely i think it does and that's that's
one thing robert when when you're going after
checkmate it can be very easy to lose track of
how much you've sacrificed and all of a sudden
your opponent gives up his queen you say ah i've
succeeded you know i wanted the queen but you've
stacked you know like two rooks in two pieces
and all of a sudden you have no pieces left so
now alexia has taken on e5 posing uh sam with
that very same decision does he go queen h6 or
does he actually take back on e5 and open up
that d file which might be to black's favor
right queen h6 there are even ideas eventually
with knight to c2 you know tactically could
potentially pan out knight to d3 as well it's
tough to evaluate such a position because white
could be in danger of losing several pawns but the
king on g8 is so unsafe so he does go with queen
h6 and f6 is one idea don't love it but it's
a way to try to stop a piece of point in g5 i
suppose f6d e i guess is what he wants and then if
rookie five bishop b2 now if you go knight c2 here
one line would be okay so he's taken so knight
g5 knight f6 i guess protects h7 and there's
also queen f6 where you give the h7 pawn but you
save your king so rook d4 is to be considered here
d5 and bishop g5 i think but that's also very
complicated for bishop b2 i think rook takes
d5 and bishop b2 is the key okay so like rook
d4 knight c2 using rook d5 bishop d5 bishop
yes two defensive yeah that's just you're
crushing me on the dark squares yeah yeah
yeah so that's not good so rook d4
played he's got to find a move here
maybe f5 f5 what can i also the
queen e7 to get out of this pin
then i maybe go bishop b2 but i understand
then you go f5 and i also have queen fate as
well maybe to try to trade the queens i'm getting
desperate i'm being honest with you i'm getting
like ultra defensive no but i understand what
you're saying i mean i'm at first i thought it's
crushing because of the dark script but with the
files being open notice that the knight is kind of
immobilized because of the threat of rookie one
at least until the bishop moves out oh my gosh
and actually after f5 there's queenie one check
in some variations you have to be very careful
although then it takes and go bishop out so
that's not mate but it is very dangerous i agree
right so what a weird position we have
and and i don't envy the players with two
minutes especially essentially on both of their
clocks to calculate these insane complications
yeah and this is where i want to just say
robert and i think you'll side with me here
you can look at the eval bar and say well
it's so simple you know this this and this
or you look at the computer's top choice how
can they miss it uh it's very important to
understand how complicated this position is the
computer makes everything seem simple but try
to understand the sort of nuance and complexity
and the amount of candidate moves that need to
be calculated here bishop b2 is what occurred
to me bishop b2 fb rook d5 ooh because you have
what about queen e7 after bishop b2 but then i was
going to suggest i was going to suggest rookie one
maybe there okay he's got bishop with tempo oh but
queen d7 there's knight f6 right that's a problem
although you would sack your queen oh the brook
and aids hanging that's uh something i didn't
notice at first but like queen d7 knight f6 check
takes you can you take with the bishop on f6 but
rook d7 97 the rook on 8 is hanging at the end and
so white has a ton of extra material right he's
taken on e4 but this has the error of desperation
i mean you could take on d8 and go back to f6 and
use that pin to win oh granted black will have two
pieces for a queen it's not entirely over there
but i think it essentially is yeah and he's done
precisely that good eye by you there we'll just
say it again bishop f6 threatening checkmate in
one threatening the rook the knight is well it can
capture as it just did but you lose the rook on
eight and done one other thing that i want to say
kind of what you were implying is um it is
difficult to go through all of these immense
complications for the players and i also think
when we make mistakes i am never ashamed of my
mistakes and part of the reason why is like when
i see the evaluation part jump i'm like okay
clearly i didn't see something but we're also
going through that same process of there are so
many different possibilities and that queen sacks
that we're talking about earlier those look very
interesting and if we were playing we wouldn't
have an evaluation bar so we'd just be like hey
this looks like good compensation and compensation
isn't always concrete it's more like this gives me
a chance and so the players if they blunder if
they make some kind of inaccuracy it's almost
always not a one move thing it's usually like oh
shoot i missed the fourth move down that you know
third variation that i was calculating so yeah no
i i could totally yeah completely agree with you
robert and you know one analogy i make sometimes
is the basketball imagine if you could every time
that a shot was released or in football that aaron
rodgers or jimmy garoppolo jimmy garoppolo throws
an interception every second has but let's
say every time steph curry shot the basketball
you would immediately know whether the shot
went in as it was flying toward the basket
would you would you watch a version of basketball
that had that probably not that would take all the
fun out of it right and i encourage people to
do the same thing try to look at the position
of your own eyes try to appreciate some of
the complexities try to see you know if the
shot goes in or not that's where part of the fun
lies and people struggle to find the truth it's
not only about oh you know oh the computer said
this you know what a big mistake what a blunder
it's about appreciating the search for truth
the heart and the soul that these players put
in uh to try to be as precise and as you
know as nuanced as possible in their play
for sure and i mean even this position i see
the bar saying plus 3.15 over there that's not
how the players are thinking serrano is like i'm
losing but i don't see how i lose the game and uh
savion's thinking wait oh shoot this knight's
coming to f3 to check i have to be careful and
so he's gotten back his queen but there are
no weaknesses yeah black is that material but
no weakness in king e6 look at this everything
is safe and sound here h4 i like he's playing
okay e3 not yet but i'm looking for the
right time for an ethernet move i would go a4
and i would go 95 back to d3 or to g4 right give
me the g4 square for my knight now with white you
would consider taking on d5 that's whoa whoa whoa
e3 now three so tempting it is a four he's gone
but okay three zero the pawn e3 e3 take it take d5
i think you have to do it i'm just too scared of
that bishop wait a minute 91 oh that's a nice move
though queen eight to take on e3 with the queen
this is not i mean it's probably still winning but
it's not easy it has borderline fortress yeah it
is borderline fortress and f4 is probably
a very good move because the g6 pawn is
going to be hurt if black loses that deep on
that's still not over in that event of that you
could it's how easy is it to miss a fork here
or something like that and actually if you do
play f4 there's the possibility that you can't
make progress in your pawns because you have d5
d5 oh rook d5 was so nice there and i might
have been winning but this this still might
be a fortress it's how do you make progress
here exactly you have to bring your king but
that's so dangerous you're playing with fire
and you just can't push a pawn there's no break
this is i think it's a fortress drop this is a
dream rook f7 rook f5 how are you going to stop
me right the king just cannot penetrate
sort of the fifth ring even if it does
you're only asking for trouble i would be careful
with white hair about moves and stuff like that
right there could be a timely knight f5 yeah
in the g3 pawn yeah lexi is just saying all
right you're not going to push me around here
no you're just going back and forth and there's
no way to make progress because you can't go
pawn h4 to h3 which is what you need to do
yeah that's exactly right it's all about the pawn
breaker you have to dislodge one of the pieces now
yeah i've seen this idea of bringing
the king around to you know b4 but but
the rook extends its influence throughout the
whole board that's the strength of a rook exactly
and just knight h6 knight to uh g4 kingdom king
g8 the thing is black doesn't need to do anything
yeah there's no attempts even there's no way to
force zooxan there's simply absolutely nothing
uh oh yeah king d5 broke out five is an important
note you don't don't bring your knight f5
almost works right hit g3 rookie seven but not
quite keeping the rook on f5 is just sensible
i think it makes sense that that sam is playing
this out he's definitely torturing serrano he
is making him find these moves but by and large
i mean there is very little to play for here oh
oh wait a minute why did he allow that because
he's got oh my god but now if you go rook f7 i
will take on f7 right you have to be careful you
don't need to allow that it might still be a draw
wow it's still a fortune oh fifty movers oh that
was all of my weight i think we're in a draw
it puts 50 moves it's still a draw there
robert knight g4 yeah there's just no way
to make progress yeah that was awesome um you
know we can just bring up the previous game very
quickly because uh even though the queen got
to e7 and the kings on e6 you just go knight
g4 knight h6 and the best you have is some kind
of uh check and a king comes up so what a way to
end that game a 50-move rule draw and we have a
sharp game once more there's an extra pawn on c4
for black but it takes a lot to keep it and white
is ahead in development white is pinning this
knight and the sacrifice is typical the knight is
still pinned take with the pawn here danya these
type of lines are so so tricky and we saw this was
it yesterday or was it two days we did see that
yesterday yesterday right we saw this uh variation
with queen v6 cast queen side c5 so this is not
actually the batmanic uh they have wait it is
above nx uh or um it's somewhere between a mosque
and above enoch usually in the mainland bob and
the bishop comes to g2 right that's why i was just
uh dragging bishop over there so it's different
and we can highlight some of those differences
in the sense that you often play c5 as black in
the budvinic because you're trading bishops on g2
and exposing the light squares around the
white king but because you haven't played g3
your light squares are better defended
here from white's perspective and the
queen dropped back to c7 the palmer's on the a6
c5 now not so easy with the b5 pawn to attack
this is a modern chest at its finest how could
you explain this in 20 seconds to people i would
say black's king is safe for the time being but in
order to gain activity you have to make move like
c5 at some point and that makes the king worse
especially with bishop f3 and trading on the light
squares and for white you right now have a board
state where you are up one pawn but the pawns are
all over the place and black has potential aiming
at the d4 pawn and potentially later pushing pawns
on the queen side so the pawn a6 in the end game
could be overextended dania i have no idea how
to evaluate this position no this is crazy and the
way i like to explain these positions sometimes is
through the lens of a concept in physics which is
potential in kinetic energy you know when you're
going down the hill on a roller coaster you've
got a lot of kinetic energy that's white white
is moving his pawns around you know he's he's
making improvements to his position he's inducing
weaknesses it may look like black's very passive
but he's got a lot of potential energy when the
position uncoils if white is not prepared for that
there might be hell to pay something like knight
e5 you can see how all of black's pieces again
they look like they're pushed back back against
the wall but one or two files open and white's
position can collapse like a house of cards
totally true and right now you have to consider
b4 it's considered 95 so the position is quite
complex and that's why 7n is in the think tank
b4 always an option right that is just the move
you consider but then you look at the c4 pawn
wait that just weakened my pawn unnecessarily
what are the tactics in this position it's really
difficult to figure it out because the individual
moves both players are seeing them but it's not
about the next move it's about four moves down the
line like if you play v4 it does that allow the
c4 pawn to drop or do i have to never queen takes
a6 pinning this knight protecting c4 but then c4
pawn is pinned right like you just think about
this going forward do i have b3 here everything
is getting crazy yeah there's more traffic than
rush hour and san francisco here i mean there's
everything is going on and this is actually
happening queen decent size away from that pawn
on a6 didn't want to open up the rook is what i
gather yeah clearly this is equal zero zero
zero yeah obviously uh of course mr barr um
hmm what does white even do how do you even
think about what to do here because if you go d
e which he does you open up that a a bishop but
you could not allow black to form that on phalanx
right but g2 is hanging because you have a
castle maybe oh and then c3 for black potentially
you have to use vc but i was gonna pin that knife
that was the idea no i i'm with you there i think
that it's certainly valid and actually might
just be a good move but there are some counter
shots very quickly for black as well so it's not
so straightforward and castling queen side as
mentioned you know there's c3 as uh potentially
this bishop takes g2 your knight and a4 isn't
exactly the happiest piece who made bishop c6 to
defend the knight and trap the opposing knight
all these are possibilities here yeah i mean the
it seems after castles that the evaluation general
uh graham has to build bars filed a
lawsuit against the move castles long
i was going to bring that in and did that in an
awkward way we need three instead okay so queen
trade i mean an endgame is robert is just as
complicated as the middle game here right and
you know there's these asymmetrical pawn structure
where white has more upon the king side black has
these pawns on the queen side are they strengths
are the weaknesses the pawn c4 could fall very
quickly so what moves would i consider for black
at this point i guess bishop d5 comes to mind
maybe bishop takes g2 as well do i trade on e3 or
allow the capture on e6 i don't think i allowed
no that pawn on f6 becomes so strong right and
now you can go to f7 if you uh end up trading any
city you sleep on it yeah i mean this is just you
rely so heavily on your intuition here if you're
a human i mean this is if i had to envision how
magnus carlsen let's say trains with his coach
this is what i imagine like he solves positions
like these you know he gets two hours to think
about the best move for white um and actually
training in these types of chaotic positions
is one of those sort of russian training
methods i think mark varetsky advocated
for that it really builds your intuition i mean
calculation wise it's impossible to be precise
but what you learn are these sort of cues that
you can use to sort of make heads or tails
of these very chaotic positions but i'm
completely failing in that regard right now
i still don't know what's going on yeah this is a
wild position and sevien down on the clock down on
the scoreboard he really wants to get this game
but after knight takes c5 it does look like that
black king is in more danger than white's king
even though white's king is uncastled that could
be a good thing because you don't know where the
checkmate's coming from not really the clearest of
attacks coming your way and knight b7 is weirdly
a move yeah i'm considering shutting down your
bishop on a8 and also opening my queen to your
a7 pawn yeah just feeling like black's king is
going to be some trouble he does
precisely that now queen takes g2
is that a move it certainly is it's worth
considering and after queen g2 there could be some
kind of queen h3 check if you need to trade the
queens i don't want to trade queens necessarily
but if i need to and i can also just play rook to
f1 slide my rook to safety knight's under attack
a7 is under attack a lot to calculate absolutely
no i agree i have i think we share the feeling
here that white seems to be slowly but surely
getting the upper hand here uh initiative wise
now rook f1 i was thinking about b3 but then if
you take on da the king has well maybe b3 because
if if knight takes d then bishop before check aha
you're trying to just go for a quick checkmate
but after b3 there may be some rook a4 move which
not only stops bishop b4 but attacks for c4 pawn
it is getting just so intense right now he plays
rook f1 and b3 certainly a possibility here and
there it goes the ambulance i don't know if you
can hear the sirens but i don't know if they're
coming for white's king or from blacks exactly man
robert we're on the same page way too much today
i'm worried about me not about you in this
situation i'm worried about you not about me so
uh now b3 rook a4 what if you throw in a bishop
b4 check and you go rookie 8 no that definitely
does work a knight d3 check i mean it could
work i love sacrificing other people's pieces
you learn well because i've been doing it for
years and that is something that you want to
accomplish bringing your rook to e8 and b3 does
help with a very concrete threat of bishop before
not just check but checkmate just to show
that on the board quickly after b through
like queen e5 here comes bishop b4 the king
is stuck in the center and you're just in
big trouble another one of those ideas there are
instances where rook takes h4 has to be considered
rookie rookie played he does set up that discovery
queen takes a seven is the most tempting move what
does he have planned against that oh my lance
there's an idea there are many different ideas
there we're trying to like you're trying to
stack your queen on f1 at some point and then
a perpetual with knight t4 knight f3 so beautiful
we've got to show you wait no but 297 guards d4 oh
my gosh we both were going for the same mechanism
it doesn't work we'll show them the analysis
heroes knight f3 check king d1 queen f1 we're
looking at rookie one and knight d4 back to f3
because the king has to go back and forth from d2
to c2 but we forgot the queen could backtrack and
take on d4 because otherwise this would just be a
repetition but the queen takes the knight and then
white wins he's running out of time and he
goes b3 he simply ignores the threat on the
a bishop preparing bishop before but what if
serrano just mops up a8 and then e8 up bishop
before wins white's queen look at that rook
on h8 it mobilizes exactly the right moments
yeah this is pretty crazy castles can watch
this castle oh my gosh casting like inside
here that just might be a crusher he did it he
doesn't i forgot the king could move because he's
been there so long but i remember now i would not
take the bishop i would just go something like f3
oh to get the queen away from the defense of
the king over here i would this is where you
find some sort of a crush you do not just take the
bishop i guess you can can you play also like rook
fte1 threatening some kind of bishop g4 check with
amazing i don't think it really works out but i'm
just looking at all the tactical possibilities in
a position like this yeah and f4 is also possible
by the way mm-hmm this bishop remains underrated
okay oh okay so he turns i mean this makes sense
bishop c4 rook c8 though has to be reckoned
with true there's rook d4 i guess that uh
um and what's white one pawn for the time
being with f7 and b3 probably are just
falling this is winning king b1 game one
is bishop d5 check if the knight came back
oh that's exactly what we should do oh he
misses it he missed the check rook d2 though
knight e3 but then takes an and and oh careful
anesthesiologist me oh my 92 8 would be mate
you're right oh my goodness covers the d2 square
we saw in anastasia's mate possibility yesterday
in that match knight of one back okay i thought
you'd go for the trick serrano's he's not showing
okay well i guess this is completely winning
yeah take on f7 and there should be six okay not
finding the bishop he's the four the bishop
works something about them he doesn't like
yeah i guess it's just hard to recognize in
certain positions yeah f7 bishop oh bishop
boom goes the dynamite and black remains only
with a king and a bishop what a game robber what
a game oh my gosh and they're out of time i wasn't
even looking at the match and neither were they
well we do have the five minute portion
in the books it is a five to three lead
for alexei sarana and donna does that surprise
you at all because sebian according to smart chess
predictions was the slight favorite in the five
minute portion but serrano he looked sharp under
the duress of time trouble he did and i think what
lexi was able to do is find that medium he was a
little bit sloppy at the start of the match but
so practically strong he found ways to complicate
the situation in sevien's time trouble and then
robert toward the end of the match i think he
started apportioning his time very very well all
led up to that final game absolutely incredible
complications which both of them handled so
expertly but sarah now with moves like queen takes
a seven castles long the ability to find these
tactical blows quickly he jumps out to a two-point
lead so ball squarely in samuel savion's court
but everything left to be decided here the fight
is still ahead absolutely and we may need a year
to figure out what was going on in the game and we
also need some time to recover because our brains
were just all over the place we are going to take
a quick break and when we return we'll be back
for the three minute plus one second increment
portion of this junior speech his championship
match between sam sebian and alexis serrano you
will not want to miss the action brought to you
by chess.comchestkid.com we'll be back shortly
so
and we are back ready for the three minute plus
one second increment time patrol of this matchup
between samuel sevian and alexei saranac daniel
we had an excellent start to this match a 5-3 lead
at the moment for sarana if you were coaching
sevien what would you tell him how can he mount
a comeback in this match that was indeed
an incredible five-minute segment and as i
often say it's it's important to put things in
perspective uh and to realize for savion that
the games were close it was better much better for
example in the first game i don't think he needs
to make any global opening changes i do think that
moscow variation he's entering with black um maybe
he did a little bit of work there uh perhaps he
will go for the standard bobbinic variation so
that's one thing i think he needs to think about
in terms of the time management uh in some of the
critical moments robert i think maybe he hesitated
a little bit too much in terms of calling some of
alexis bluffs so that's basically what i would
tell them maybe a little bit more confident in
terms of the critical moments but by and large
it was close and the three-minute segment can go
either way it was so well played by both of them
and again we see the opening that they started the
five-minute segment with this english with knight
before yeah i'm a little tired of this opening to
be honest i wish we could get something new but
we do have a difference because that knight was
coming to a4 with the queen still on d1 and some
of the other lines now the rook is on d1 and that
should be helpful for white but look at sauron
he's closing the center putting his pawns in a
chain here the problem is you can't develop
this bishop without dropping the b7 pawn
yeah so cd and bishop f4 is a very standard way to
develop and you stop the rook from coming to b8 so
trouble could land very quickly
after rooksy won an ip5 there
um yeah he goes bishop f4 immediately so saranac
has to solve this problem asap and this upon e4
it looks good it's blunting the bishop on g2 but
it also is a pawn that requires defense by another
pawn so d takes c4 it will help black to some
extent but it may just cause too many difficulties
on the e4 for instance dc queens queen c4 e4
is under attack and if you play bishop f5 i may
even be able to play d5 just blasting through the
center and putting another attacker on the e4 pawn
right and this is definitely a critical moment uh
and and so not trying to find a way to untangle
his pieces the move b6 comes to mind but it
doesn't resolve the weaknesses on the queen
side i mean white could take on d5 and go
knight p5 he goes for queen b6 interesting
and now there's always that question do i take or
do i leave it because queen takes b6 will double
and isolate those pawns over here once you take on
d5 but you see some trades happen and maybe it's
not the most that white can get from the situation
so uh whether i allow the doubling of my own pawns
remains to be seen by taking on d5 right away
because cd you don't have time to take back on d5
because cd5 knight d5 if you take on b3 thank you
for the inter mezzo that's a check to your king
and then i take back the queen and i win a piece
so if i take on d5 black has to throw in queen six
b3 in which case white gets this semi-open file
whether that's enough for an advantage that's
another story yeah and uh the move c5 i think you
should refrain from because the queen would have
just dropped back and the pressure on d5 would
have been lifted he does go for this knight b5
i mean it certainly seems unpleasant for black
i i would not want to be in saranac's position i
think accuracy is required knight c7 you can make
it draw if you want knight b5 knight c7 is or was
i should say at this point in draw good call and
it still is so if you want to make a draw just go
back and forth but white is better here there's
no reason to do this rook d to c1 i think it's
what you just said uh it looks good for white
because the knight isn't getting trapped it's
well defended here and it can still retreat to
b5 at any moment with this back and forth yeah
i mean you could always repeat once um but
bishop g4 yeah i thought about this and now
you could choose between you could go f3 and try
to cut into that pawn wedge but that's not that
that's not necessary i mean you could also go with
e3 and it's not like the knight on c7 is going to
get trapped in fact it's white's greatest asset
yeah so he goes king f1 i like that move i think
the non-committal approach with e3 yeah there
could be some problems in the light squared
later in the game and there's some h3 ideas here
yeah i need to be careful of this bishop on g4 uh
i'm just going to push that back it does that and
g4 okay i like that now okay 5 comes to mind also
oh but then there should be four maybe or bishop
d8 you have to be a yeah a little careful there
this is an important moment and okay again i
probably can go knight b5 and evacuate his knight
right but he knows f3 he's claiming he can
do that at any time because the rook on a7
can't move and it can't be defended so
well not anymore will be a possibility
oh nice but i'm sure he sees that he's weighed the
calculus of it and that's what savvy that's what
sarnot uses king f2 now reinforces the threat
of knight before knight takes a6 exactly wasn't
available before because the check and there's
also bishop f1 improving the bishop from its
current space which is not doing much of anything
then rerouting that to f1 to put pressure on the
pawn but also the light squares because if black
plays a5 thank you so much for the b5 square right
and if you try to go bishop d3 that bishop is not
going to remain there now bishop well rook c6 this
this looks like complete and total domination on
the queen side um too many areas to draw yeah i
mean knight b5 now is just open for business and
wow he's lighting up that queen side look at this
i mean i just can't even
keep a pleasant looking face
i'm getting squeezed even though i'm just
watching this game yeah these kinds of binds
now it one has to be clear it's not like he's
going after a particular pawn i think he's just
going after black's pieces at some point rook c8
rook c6 96 so this is almost impossible to play
i would move the king away if i were black and
sort of just try to survive as long as possible
see if if perhaps sevien places a piece on a
sloppy square allow some sort of a tactic so
i wouldn't say it's over but um if he plays
this accurately white should be winning
yeah just really difficult for black to come moves
you say king h7 a possibility he was bishop a6 to
attack this rook b8 he said rook b8 goes after
the b6 keeps the pin alive there's also knight
takes f7 ideas let's say rook b8 oh because rook
c6 the rook b8 king h7 there may have been knight
takes f7 because i'm distracting your rook from
the bishop on d8 so catch he goes rook c6 instead
saying you can't attack my rook my knight covers
b7 it covers b5 i'll take your bishop no matter
where it goes oh man just gaining more space
but should be i would go back to d3 now though
you got to be a little bit careful about that
e4square that's what he does what can i just
take on no bishop f6 for like king e3 and taking
on d5 you could go eat king e3 right away yeah
why would i take an f6 when i can just do this
right yeah bishop before perhaps black should
try to liquidate but you're going to not only
lose a pawn but the pressure is going to remain
so it's not like you lose a pawn so you
lose the pawn and it's still very bad
right and look at this rook d6
move trading off a pair of rooks
i think that's a great choice yeah i was a little
bit skeptical because of bishop f6 but now i look
at it in bishop e5 and that pawn is fast and it's
over yeah rook c2 just the safe and sound method
and d5 is coming king c6 c7 d6 etc yeah i mean
this is there's some precision required but
like i said at the start of the batch robert
i i'm thoroughly impressed with the technique
uh by and large not of course the resilience and
the resourcefulness goes without saying but the
technique also uh is reminiscent of someone
very very experienced uh and uh here we see
just d6 the red carpet has been unrolled now you
intercept the bishop on h4 no f5 very precise yeah
i was actually thinking about f5 move a little
while ago he plays it and he only has to watch
out for his b2 pawn that's the one thing that
seven has to look out for but here he gets d7
and once the trade happens here comes his queen
resignation that was a fantastic positional effort
by sam oh do you see sam you see him just like
nodding his head he's getting himself into that
he's pumped right now wow and but now has not
moved i feel like sorry now is just hanging
he's like oh we'll get this opening once again i
lost one game in this line but uh it's tactical
vigorous that is a head workout right there those
are some vigorous nods by grandmaster sevien
for sure and well speaking of vigorous look at
this line that we see once again super duper
sharp the bishop on f4 is hanging and this time
seven throws and bishop takes c3 before doing
anything about this bishop on f4 so the bishop
for white stays alive and the bishop for black
has captured on c3 right what i always wonder
robert is do they look up these lines in the break
i think probably there's different approaches
some players feverishly go onto their chest space
look at files file saws some just you know down an
espresso and close their eyes for a couple minutes
something tells me that um these players are
doing more of the former because this is a
very theoretical heavy uh match um i you know i
wonder whether they in fact did that what do you
think robert i think they did they just probably
looked up one or two lines because you can't do
everything in a seven minute break or however
long they have so you just quickly just look
in line i haven't enjoyed the position i've been
getting from the black side of this opening let
me go check just a couple lines and yeah here
there's no real mating attack that i'm seeing
and the queens have just come off the board
g5 is falling and that's probably bothering
sebian but it is even material opposite-colored
bishops the one thing dania i'm sure you're going
to highlight this as well this bishop coming to f6
at some point could be a big nuisance i think that
this bishop coming to f6 could be a really big
nuisance um robert stop copying what i'm saying
you keep repeating everything i'm saying it's
ridiculous you know it's telepathy at this point
yeah and i think that again this is the one thing
that surprises me somewhat is the speed with which
sardar goes into these lines uh in the e4 and
himself but he's not getting that much i mean
at best maybe his position is symbolically for
choice but even that i doubt because there might
be a bunch of exchanges down the e file and just
a draw and we see the nitrate being offered and
seven goes i respectfully decline let
me point on a4 to get after your c3 pawn
and it's just an important little mini lesson
here if you take here he's probably concerned
this bishop coming to f6 the d5 pawn being the
target and even though there's no immediate
checkmating net that black has
to worry about it just feels
like you have a slightly worse position and
that's probably why he went for the activity
rather than just swapping knights and the
bishop on d7 will not have the same strength
that a bishop on d4 does yeah the move rook c1
if you have to make a move like that that means
things are not necessarily going particularly
well i mean i don't think it's disastrous but
the more i look at this position robert initially
i thought yeah that bishop is really good on d4
uh you know mating threats but if sebian is
careful that weakness of the pawn on c3 that's
more of a static weakness and that's something
that's going to saddle white for essentially the
rest of the game unless he finds a way to somehow
train it off i'm with you and you know what next
the bishop 24 looks good but you can't just claim
i have a good bishop now my position's all great
in fact black as you're saying has in a quick
threat he takes the pawn against c3 directly
and bishop a force should be three yep watch
out for 92 at the end of that variation where
you take on b3 and knight two so the rook needs
to stay protecting the square the king came out
two knight a2 another free pawn no i guess he
wants knight d2 and what he's banking on is this
again the possibility of matrix and the bishop
covers the square on e8 but okay so let's see
what happens knight b5 bishop f6 i don't like this
for black anymore yeah i don't like them a bishop
takes v3 at all because now the bishop dominates
the knight now black is paralyzed he's tied down
to the eighth ranked rubber oh it's the best don't
play d4 was rookie forward cage four that could be
made this way was that just winning uh it looked
pretty strong that was a great catch savion is
still nodding i would not be nodding here if i
were black i think he's trying to pump himself up
rather than actually thinking that he's doing well
yeah but he's got 30 seconds and he's and he's
worse and things have gone why does serrano have
two minutes and seven seconds i don't understand
it's crazy this guy this guy's a madman so he
goes rook to d5 ending the knight don't go c5
no rook c5 would allow the back rank mates he's
bringing the knight to e6 it seems like cold
blooded defense now by sam i do like what he's
doing quite a bit rook c2 is possible now and rook
g2 even ideas oh look at that stopping f4 rook h3
or h4 h5 trying to get the outside pass pawn this
is fantastic defense by by sevi getting the knight
to e6 but h4 now being prepared by sarah now this
is still complicated it might end in a draw right
but it's not so easy to play with 20 seconds left
to your opponent's v55 so i would start pushing
the pawns on the queen side i mean both f4 f4
is very dangerous now because you can't take
there's rook d a checkmate do not play very 57
in every c3 attack begins it does f5 comes then
where's the knight going to c5 and the efficient
g5 watch out for bishop g5 bishop h6 oh you oh
you too careful watch out that way five changes i
wouldn't go rooksy three wait qg five vote h3 and
then rookie chase me or rook c3 also ah is there
no defense no defense wow simply nothing that
they do look at that bishop dominating everything
too good yeah oh that's that's a sad move to
play yeah sag and rook c7 okay doesn't win the a7
which you could have done before go king g6 okay
rookie three check king of seven and rook c3 and
get this rook in c file yeah the knight is just
completely just not capable of guarding everything
and he's gonna go a5 once the rook comes to
eight so he's not losing his pawn for now
excuse me um wait a minute rook c4 would be a nice
move here oh my gosh if he plays rook c4 that's
even now rook c4 i mean there's nothing to
calculate the pawn race isn't even close
i would do it i mean he's got a minute in 20
seconds yeah but you're a ridiculous human being
so rook c4 he's going to play it i know elections
but knight takes on e5 yeah yeah and g5 it's just
very direct okay fair enough fair enough yeah
only a psychopath like me with play rooks before
i wasn't going that far i was just well saying
that it was an unnecessary tactical sequence
that still was very good thank you all right i'll
take that as a compliment so check f6 came over
i agree that it was unnecessary but begrudgingly
and uh a win there for for sarnath that is a
definitely a setback for sam who i felt like
robert and correct me if i'm wrong was confident
he got out of the opening with a good end game
and just things misfired a little bit there again
the time management serrano is getting away
with with playing very fast and here we have
an old school rook g1 that was a line put
into practice by vasily vanciuk i think in
the 90s and we have a sicilian so we have an
e4 so it is sevien who decides to change his
first move and that last game we had highlighted
the bishop on the dark squares that's what it all
came down to and that is why sauron won that
game so for sevien he was fine he was doing
well but the long term pressure got to him and
it was sarna who took that game yeah this one
the rook g1 punji iv where is your attack
coming from exactly you push the pawn
that's all good and fun what next another bishop
on f3 we saw one on f6 now there's one on f3
i didn't like e4 right just keep that bishop
this line is both positional and tactical yeah
i was going to say we often see end games and
what white is going for here is the sort of
how do i even phrase it there's a bunch of
these semi-weak squares that black has on b6
uh white's got the initiative but if
black can resolve the immediate problems
obviously white has taken certain liberties on
the king's side and created weaknesses of his own
wow the point here is like bishop bishop h3 so
if i go bishop here you're rook d7 i bishop h3
attacking your if it drops his bishop to e6 you
can just trade on d8 the knight can't take back
because the e5 pawn falls the bishop can't take
back because the knight d6 check knight takes b7
so the king had to take and i would even consider
f4 here for what bishop g2 can't be played because
the knight's hanging just you know the movie like
i mean it can be played it which is one of the
night i think yeah it is impossible to do that
just don't recommend it yeah just want to make
it very very quick accurate okay so f4 played
wow following the advice of one grandmaster
uh we all make mistakes every now and then
but the point is just to open the position up
uh the king is in the center for black not the
end of the world without queens on the board
but not e5's under threat if you take me on f4 i
take with the bishop my bishop one f4 looks very
strong there yeah you can still get checkmated
rook t3 king c8 knight b6 there i mean it's it's
yes and that happens obviously rook d3 will
be met with king e8 okay so he covers the b6
square entirely which i like yeah it's hard to
say who's better here i mean it it's even hard
to say who has the initiative really i like
white's position because i also think that
the queen side pawns will be easier to push at
some point and 96 is going not just for the long
term but immediately this b7 pawn if they take me
on d6 i'll take back and give me the bishop pair
right i mean it's it's also the one thing is that
white has advanced his king side pawns very far
which does make it easy for black to create
a pass pawn right he can just play f5
but obviously that is not significant with so many
pieces on the board it's just like in the event of
a total liquidation upon end game it's hard to say
who that would favor it might be black so i think
sevien ha maybe c4 c5 he's got to keep an eye
on the possibility of liquidation and evaluated
carefully and for sarina he's looking at g6 h6
at some point as well trying to open up uh the
king side his rook on h8 isn't doing so much and i
would look to play h6 but for now h6 there's just
g takes h6 and there's a problem uh down that side
right so rook d8 by alexi chasing that bishop away
and um i guess after bishop a3 yeah i do like i
mean i like the two bishops especially in an open
board like this uh things are you know so nice to
play actively here in order to compensate for that
and um we'll just quickly show also the current
odds we all like the bobbing heads here and it's
been sort of zigzagging sine wave kind of thing
back and forth which reflects uh you know how
close this match is yeah and it's really cool
because it's brought to us by chess goals.com
so if you feel stuck at your rating you can use
the innovative 12-week data-driven premium study
plan and that can help benefit your chess there is
a 25 off using the code jscc there's a command for
it so you know get involved enjoy it it's a great
product and brought to us by chess goals awesome
and by the way saranac at the 62 odds right now
it's uh gone well for him thus far but this game
is it going well from or after bishop g4 if
you take it might taking with the h pawn and
then going rook h3 and trying to get your h7 bomb
yeah i'm a little concerned about knight before
um because if you put a rook on well i guess
you could play rook c3 check and then you could
shift your king to the b file you just don't
want to go a3 and blunder knight a2 check
yeah so that happens so your points of rook
c3 there is knight a2 but not yet because it's
check and so you don't have to move your king away
right can you play can i play a3 because you can't
take with your knight there's rook c3 is good
and if rook takes then the knight is pinned to
the rook the knight is attacked so oh now maybe
knight d5 should be played by sarnath right but
it's clear that he wasn't moving he's not here to
go knight to d5 because he's thinking right now
yeah he he acquiesces but rook d3 maybe so you're
getting the bishop on f6 was under attack so yeah
oh yeah that's right i missed that drops it first
now bishop e6 fe-6 does that give black a passed
pawn or an isolated pawn the answer is both but
how do you assess this transition yeah which one
which one is it that depends on how the game goes
what is going to be its defining characteristic
c4 makes some sense here but you want to be
careful about pushing pawns here as we talked
about and create weaknesses that knight is very
jumpy it can sort of chisel its way in sideways
position king b2 instead i'm beginning to like
black's position here yeah i am as well and e5
was played if c4 there are knight f4 ideas where
my next actually go to h5 winning your piece
and there's the d3 square that i'm looking
at you have to be very careful here
if you are um sebi and actually rook it's a rookie
three i just take on g5 e5 is immune to capture
because it forks on the d3 right and here comes
the king oh gosh cementing everything yeah i think
e6 this is not looking good because white has
not gotten off the ground on the queen side that
pawn is passed right now it's not isolated i'm
with you and g5 is falling knight before check
follow rook takes g5 i guess bishop e5 there but
that's winning oh oh what a move what a tactic
but wait a minute i wouldn't be so sure i don't
have a minute to wait i see 15 seconds left
and less for the players that's right wait wait 10
seconds here so before he's trying to calculate do
i allow the capture do i take here but if i
take those king takes and the king comes up
right but 95. oh 95 i would have cut the bishop
off but then king before but now 95 c5 checks
see that doesn't work anymore okay king d5
is going to be at times gonna move seven
here comes c67 there's a thing simultaneously
and then where's the but where's the black king
go at the end of this oh bishop of course this
is losing oh my god losing on time and position
and seven he is just did you see that he breathed
a sigh of relief and he grabs a swig of his water
he's ready for the next game we have another
queen to nimzo wow and sarina i mean he is
a level-headed guy but we could just tell he was
rattled that was an incredible turn of events and
when you get into those minor peace end games and
i just want to say one thing um and i have to give
credit here to my good friend peter gionato's
video master of the charlotte chess center
he noticed this when a player during a match
takes a drink of water it usually means that
they're comfortable with their position okay you
never get take whatever drink you have next to you
never take a drink of that if your position
is bad it's only when your position is good
and here we see seven digging into that water that
was an incredible game well his position was good
because the game was over but until that moment
he wasn't taking any drinks and he can breathe a
quick sigh of relief but the action continues we
have sarina on the white side of this position we
did see him eventually win this game in this from
this position where the queens were traded though
on the g6 square so this time the queen is on
d2 no queen trades going right after the g5 pawn
and i actually do not like the opening choice
from sevien we've seen this time and time again
it doesn't feel like he's getting the types
of positions that he is super at home in and
especially with the queen's remaining on the
board donya it feels like black's king is in
far worse shape than white's king is at least
without a doubt um so i feel like my assessment
of this line is sort of swinging back and forth i
can't tell if i can't tell if if i approve of this
choice for white i feel like one game it goes that
way one game it goes this way it's hard to say
oh so c5 knight whoa bishop how would
he see that so quickly that's crazy
that's a counter-attacking move seven saw that
instantly that's hilarious oh my gosh right like
we have rook d1 rook c8 and both bishops are in
trouble here uh we're just going to take a step
back bring up the analysis board so we can show
you some of these lines here and the problem for
for black is that if you move the rook to attack
the bishop i take your bishop and attack your
queen in the process so you have to find this with
bishop d3 and he trades on f8 so we are getting
into a position with a series of exchanges and
white is even in material but has an extra pawn
in front of the king so dania when you look at
this is h4 a huge threat for white because if
we just go back a second that's beautiful h4 queen
h4 rook h1 would have trapped this queen over here
right and that's why he goes queen f6 on pinning
himself i'm inclined to say probably the position
is about equal so why does the weak pawn structure
on the queen side black has a very weak pawn on g5
and you do not want to give that pawn up because
that would also fork the king and the rook i i
think that it's going to fizzle out uh into into
a draw shortly well one thing i'm considering is
if we do trade queens and i play the c4 move right
because there's a pin on your rook if i'm thinking
long term in the king and pawn end games do i
have the potential to spring free and outside pawn
for white but then i also have this side of the
board with a pass pawn from black we have extra
pawns and opposite flanks and who is that favorite
i like white's position right now because of the
pawns in front of the king and the rook on d4
pinning this pawn can apply more pressure along
the d file yeah you could consider rook d6 to
have rook e6 in store against c4 i think that
i i do agree i think white's got the blockade
he's got the slightly safer king and rook t6 it
follows but savion is very good at defending these
types of positions and not giving a lot of chances
uh so you know alexei trying what what he can
against c4 is not currently a threat because of
d takes c4 right that's a very important
point c4 dc4 hits the queen and actually
black just wins in the spot so don't go about
and do that and he plays a4 so just trying to
put his pawn on a square protected by the rook
it also stops any b5 ideas for black if you're
trying to stop c4 and it's not so easy for either
player to make moves because if you make a move
like king f6 for instance is there a queen h7 no
there's not but you just have to keep an eye on it
and the same goes for white i mean if you abandon
your king queenie queenie two could follow
so i think neither side is going to be willing
to take now queenie is an interesting move if
you take on d5 black is going to trade and
then make perpetual check with queen e2
exactly so everything comes off check check
back and forth or if your king goes to h3
i've checked on f1 you could go h4 though and
then after gh you could consider rook t5 but
i don't like it because a4 is also hanging at
the end of that exactly and i think that we can
tunnel on that pawn or we can forget about it
but at some point it's going to be relevant and
h4 is an interesting idea to follow up with king
to h3 and try to get the pawn back but with the
queen on e8 so strong eventually coming to e1
you probably don't have it in you to play h4
right queen e3 i guess rook d3 something like
that but queen f4 so i'm not sure what oh then
rook takes d5 that's a funny little sequence
that is funny rookie six now that is a pretty uh
that continuation signals to me that savion is
thinking about taking over the initiative here
right his rook was passively defending now
it's on an open file in front of the queen
trying to infiltrate so what do you do here
don do you think um okay can you have two
just to keep everything close but can i
swing to the h file you can but then i'll
go back to g2 okay so he takes oh i'll buckle
up queen d4 oh who's winning here okay this is
getting tricky because that's queen two this
is a rook h1 check there is f6 rook takes g5
okay so i guess white has to bail out well what
about rookie five here if i just shut your queen
down oh okay queen d3 played and cute h6 rook d6
check the king has to go back to g7 or rook d6 f6
oh you sneaky sneaky guy okay so rook d6 f6 takes
kg7 is he gonna do it no he's not well there's i
think i could just move my rook back there too i i
just might rook away so i don't think it works out
but we don't have much time okay we have the case
going back and forth and whoa so we're going for
a win so there's check and queenie one there must
be some other things here that uh for black that
can i mean the pawn a4 i said it was irrelevant
but maybe now it's relevant i did mention there
would be a time that it would be important
no that time has come because rook g5 king h6
there instead i can't tell if they're repeating
moves or if one of the sides is making progress
rookie five now rookie five mentioned that move
earlier he plays it and there's queen e4 check
but then the king comes back to g7
two seconds now all of a sudden serrano slipped
really into two [ __ ] okay we're getting kicked
no broke three rook f3 oh you can take on a
three and he does it because it's a bailout
and i think a draw or it looks like it should
be but nobody's going to probably player oh
okay he's gonna queen seven queen eight
double king of six let's create a check
i think white can actually if white can win
a seven black is still going to have to give
perpetual right and king g5 is very risky so
he goes quinn back to f6 good idea yeah drop
now one of the sides could blunder here and
yeah it's always b5 trade pawns king gets
the b pawn king gets the g pawn that was all
there was a lot of tension there in that game
and it is just like by the way
sarina he's at 3k but just exactly
yep he's great that's a great place to be that
is a great place to be and look at this set up by
sevian he brings his bishop snakes it via
d3 to c2 center is well protected here is
knight b4 we were talking about these sort of
spanish positions where you get knight to b4
this looks kind of like it uh could have come
from the spanish but it's from a sicilian
right we've got several of those positions that
kind of have the overtones of our rai lopez
but but this is a good one for black i think he's
got the two bishops and he's got the king's indian
idea we keep just referencing other openings
but he's got the king's indian idea of going f5
yes uh you know f5 also knight f4 please take me
on f4 i want to open up my kingzinian like bishop
on g7 so here queen b8 it looks like a
set well speaking of sad moves bishop
c8 okay but is that a really because a
long range piece it can also support f5
true and maybe even some potential on the h3
square a sacrifice at the right moment but
i didn't really feel good about seeing bishop of
c8 that's fair that d6 spawn is also something to
keep an eye on right and i was looking at queen
b8 and rook f8 to c8 you know i'm making the
rook look silly on eight for the time being but
not that big a deal right hmm so what to do now
bishop e3 just developing his bishop for sure
f5 is a double-sided coin that also weakens
the position it's important to know knight g5
is actually possible i think at 496. ah nice
looking you find an attack because f4 looks like
it wins a piece cutting off the bishop from the
knight but 96 takes politics it looks like you
can take a bishop on e3 but watch out for e7
with check and that would win the black i would
consider f4 anyway and 96 just go queen f6
and then try to get f3 and even that if
that means sacrificing the exchange which
way i will i would go f4 here i could buy
that he plays that force nine h4 he also after
takes can play queen okay he did it but
queen he said i don't know about that
he still has your idea of f3 the e6 pawn can
be attacked another time i bring the rook
in and knight d5 i can just take on e6 because
knight d5 queen e6 97 check looks fancy because
my queen is pinned and under attack but king
f7 saves the queen on e6 i do get away with it
something about this though now even if black
plays f3 though white can even go g4 and i feel
like black doesn't quite have enough firepower
to um you know to make things happen when push
comes to shove now queen takes c6 can be allowed
in that end game white has compensation number
oh yeah getting this knight to d5 and the c file
always is compensation i don't know how sufficient
it is but that is uh what i guess seven is relying
on also the b7 pawn can be captured if the queen
takes an e6 too early so it's not so easy here for
white or black to move i'd probably rook a1 to c1
gearing up for the queen to capture on e6
and trying to take control of the open file
right and um yeah the time situation it's so hard
to play these positions in a blitz game because
you can get easily kind of drawn
into the rabbit hole of trying to
understand the nuances of the position which
savion is currently doing he's again a minute down
on the clock and he does go for knight q5 so let's
see how this unfolds okay so using the queen as a
block gator knight c7 is a threat watch out for
the fork you go says look for open file stopping
it queen g4 i can take and bring my knight back
to f6 but i see what your point there's knight e7
check but at the end of that knight
takes e4 okay none of that happens
rook d1 now very important to reinforce
the control it's not about the knight
it's about the control over the d5 square right
it's the square more than what piece is on as
you're saying but you do not want to take with
a pawn right as that isolates your own pawn and
it will allow the e pawn to push it well you do
now but you know unless it's a fork or something
of course so bishop f8 protecting d6 and that's
good news for the rook on c6 it is free to
roam around the board but it feels like a bind
as it doesn't actually seem like black is up a
pawn because the pawn d6 can't go anywhere right
and we have in in some ways a situation similar
to the last game where you know both sides are
unwilling to take the big risk um and so this game
might also just peter out into a draw because
neither side is making progress but i think
saranat is making progress nobody cancelled the
idea of just attacking on the king's side so
in many ways white's position optically
looks very appealing with that rook on d5 but
if saranac can circumvent it and buy himself time
if he pushes the pawn through to g4 things could
get very unpleasant for sebbian and the issue
is because seven is down a pawn and black is
playing on both sides of the board right now
his queen on e2 stops g5 but now the queen
might need to protect the d5 rook or if you take
on c5 here it is the the d-pawn became a c pawn
and the bishop on e7 feels a little bit better
but the pawn e5 feels a bit worse clearly now
it's up upon black is playing for a win white's
got pretty good drawing chances yeah the pawn on
e5 as he said weak but we'll see he opens up the
c5 square for his bishop potentially there's also
ideas now still of going g5 g4 the attack can
actually be very strong in these positions
right now as well as a possibility in the near
future just planting the bishop not well no not
now the h5 would check what do you what does what
you though you can get checkmated in two moves oh
yeah takes takes and then g3 check and trying to
yeah goodbye queen h6 and f2 is hanging by the way
now what if bishop queen g4 queen c7 going
after f6 king f6 queen d8 check king g6
i see you trying to move around h4 he plays it
that's right but there's got to be a back rank
mating oh my goodness g3 f3 and then queen
h3 is there but why does queen g5 check
and they take on h5 with check and then yeah so
dinah's point is if you hit f3 you take there's
queen h3 mate but queen g5 check i take on h5 will
check i take another check funny thing is if you
play g3 and f3 black is actually threatening the
move queen h3 yes exactly to give up the queen
from i was thinking about that too before like if
you make some random move like bishop e5 is queen
h3 check takes in g2 and g1 equals queen me let's
get to the live position bishop g3 check played
and the throat of queen g5 is undoubtedly scaring
yes whoa okay i'm glad he didn't take on f3 that
would have lost a piece so he is stopping that
at all costs i really like that idea actually he
didn't throw in queen g5 check and now he may be
paying the price for that right because the bishop
covers the square so is he getting checkmated here
even queen d3 check might be a winning end game
or queen f3 takes the pawn with check yeah you're
absolutely right look at that pawn on h4 bishop d2
the king can't get in for black oh my lands the
king can't get in so wait what about king f6
well four who's winning no it's black
he won't be three so that probably was
wrong okay so the king comes around and
then d7 c6 v5 that's going to be bishop
win the h4 pawn that seems good
enough it does outside passer
you got to make sure that white doesn't close
everything up but there's that b5 hole so the king
could actually head that way and the pawn can
head the other way and white's resources will be
too extended right and black does not want to be
left with the h pawn does not match the color of
the bishop but unfortunately for white you can't
trade off queenside pawns your pawn's an a5 not
in a square that allows a tree now the king is
cut off there's just no way that but okay this
is just g3 so smart defending both pawns at
the same time now the king can just walk in
well but where exactly so i'll go oh yeah you way
to say he's trying the other direction but is that
border close too i don't think it is team jesus
and bishop g oh promotion and king f3 that's nice
i think bishop g3 king f4 but you're right
he's gotta go for the promotion he does
and it's still a game but it is king d3
there was more a little bit more precise
but this is also winning commission yeah and
the pawn end game is of course winning the
king is so much closer to the pawns
yeah goodbye gobble gobble indeed
wow what a game so close savion put up a great
fight but alexi with an iron fist there nerves
of steel and he delivers another victory
the lead still stubbornly at two points
and he wants to keep his three thousand plus
rating that's what i was all about sorry not three
thousand seven seven twenty nine forty three no
slouch either and we have a benoni so the openings
have been changing in the quicker time patrol here
and what do you make of this decision from seving
to me it seems like he needs he feels the urge to
win so he's playing a sharper opening but has some
real structural damage in the form of this pawn d6
yeah i mean it's an opening that this will either
go very very well or very badly i don't think
this game will end in a draw um which is probably
precisely why it will and just we notice here that
the odds are you know they're obviously they have
increased in sarena's favor but it's not like um
smarter chess is predicting a blowout there's a
big possibility you know this could turn in one
game and i think that's precisely what sam is
trying to do he realizes okay the three-minute
portion is drawing to a close he wants to make
that run before the bullet he doesn't want to
have to deal with a two-three-point lead going
to the bullet interesting strategy we'll see if
this gamble backfires or whether it pays off well
based on the clock management thus far it seems
like it's it's not going so well now sevien he's
taking on e5 with his pawn and look at this eight
extreme the c5 i said a5 because i was thinking of
white playing a5 yeah a4 but this protected passer
on d5 the c5 pawn is a clear target and even if it
doesn't you know win that pawn it just doesn't
feel good for black to be stuck to its defense
right and 9896 is the classic plan you're
blockading the pawn um but that doesn't tell
the whole story there's so many weaknesses in this
position that that actually might not even help
um because white actually also okay so he
goes for a different strategy he goes that h5
uh he's getting the knight potentially to f4
black this is one of the good things robert about
the benoni and these types of openings is even
when everything goes wrong because of the nature
of the opening and how unbalanced it is there's
always going to be counter play regardless of how
objectively bad the position is and it looks
pretty bad too four eyes here because knight f4
i can drop my bishop back to f1 so i don't i'm
not going to take that i don't want to open up
this bishop on g7 and it just feels like a bind
and eventually white can play g3 and kick that
knight but i really want to play bishop f1 king h1
f3 bishop g1 i want to reroute my bishop to a more
useful looking diagonal this is there's just no i
mean there is a knight on f4 that looks nice but
you know you're not going to build
a build a kingdom around that knight
no and there's also a possibility for white to
take in like e5 at some moment i don't think now
is the time because uh you're not ready to put
more pressure on the bishop e5 but the point is
that you're potentially walking into a pin if you
capture on e5 which you might be ready for well
now you're not ready for it either as d6 that also
has to be considered in certain positions opening
up the diagonal tarna i think is going for a plan
where he wants to push b4 i think he wants to
target that and sebian realizing that immediately
goes for the threats here queen back to g3 again
saying no you aren't going to make anything happen
on the king side and he actually might take with
the pawn on g3 queen g3 pawn takes your knight has
to go back to h5 and go g4 if your knight goes to
f6 down goes e5 your knight comes back to f4 at
some point i may have g3 trapping your knight on
the square but 96 that is an idea that uh sarnath
has to pay attention to then i could swing to d4
so i think we're gonna see rook b1 at some point
followed by b4 well 96 was almost a possibility
you need to watch out along the d5 if this rook
is ever hanging on d1 but that's why sarna he's
put his king on h1 no knight checks nothing like
that and here i okay so here's the plan progress
bishop g1 then bishop f1 and you go after the c1
you put a rook on c1 you move the queen away and
then you play f3 i know that's a very long plan
now he wants to chase the knight away with g3
um you could consider d6 here because well no i
wouldn't go anything that drastic but something
where you go after that seep on i think makes
some sense i'm i've been looking at that idea i'm
not sure i love the inclusion of the pawn h4 but
he's saying that it won't backfire i'm actually
safe on the king's side and bishop e2 then
he has to play f3 bishop g1 at some point
yeah now f5 comes into play i agree with you i
think with that pawn on h4 um there's just enough
uh tenderness on the king side to where sevien can
start considering active counter play has sarnot
underestimated these king side chances i think he
has things started to get a little bit tight here
and the best thing that sevien is doing is he's
moving quickly in fact he's keeping pace with
sarina and the bishop on h2 that looks like a
great piece if i say so myself they are amazing
it is controlling everything really it is the
just the czar of the board here f5 it's it's time
because now you can take with the pawn on f5
as the 95 is no longer under attack so it's a
big difference this knight can swing back to
f6 if it uh has to and i'm starting to like
black's position more although knight drops the
f5 well the bishop yeah the only it is socially
distancing itself right the only the only person
uh who might like that bishop is doctor anthony
but otherwise but it might not even be about
that bishop but i think it is 965 look at this
okay queen is under attack if this pawn were on g2
i might recommend the queen sack on the f8 but the
pawn is on g3 so the bishop's not hitting the e5
square and if that's the case queen duck to b1 how
about just uh knight f6 retreat oh describe that g
pawn box and f6 is played and there's possibility
if you take on d7 queen d7 queen h3 you have to be
careful about the light squares around the white
king and here it goes uh-oh the position is opened
up i think you're right on the money queen h3 is a
huge idea e4 now the bishop opens up the bishop on
h2 robert now alexi is paying a very serious price
for that bishop when the position was closed i
mean he didn't detect it and here comes queen h3
you have to play queen f1 because nigeria was such
a big threat i wouldn't trade queensland queen f5
knight then bishop d4 and the bish one h2 clearly
not a good piece absolutely just the kitchen sink
coming along the file after knight for bishop d4
with 20 seconds on the clock now it's so hard to
play for white does he give up the e4 pawn
though i think he does because there's some
kind of queen do you want checks there's bishop
before you have to look all across the board for
the various threats right after two yeah bishop
d4 here we go uh oh that's a problem that's h3
you know time this is eight seconds i think it's
mating the gamble is looking like it's going to
pay off 470. now you've got to be precise because
queen g8 mate comes into play in certain positions
queen g4 rook f2 bishop d4 still works no oh yes
it does yeah queen d4 queen b4 nice fine there
should be four is protected because i can think
about the queen but wait a second rook f2 bishop
d4 king h1 i knew what you were going to say there
but this move king g2 that walks through h3 knight
g4 back and then there's f1 is made h2 is hanging
bishop d4 check is a threat too many avenues and
directions and threats nice should i queen g2
maybe but then bishop before yeah okay immediately
and forward f1 is made yes it is rook f1 wow
there's rookie two misplaced because the bishop is
cut off and just he vacillated too much did sarna
i think he had to decisively act on the queen side
amazing job though by sam to generate counterplay
detecting the moment and pouncing mercilessly
yeah he was playing very quickly which that's
been a struggle for him throughout this match
he's been down on the clock and he's had much less
time to figure out the complications in that game
he was keeping pace with sarina and then not only
capacity actually took a lead in the clock and was
starting to seize the momentum on the board here
we have a position where 7 is white there is this
little triangle here uh with the pawns
c6 d5 e6 and what do you make of this
opening because i don't know i don't really
mind it for either side yeah i mean it's um
okay so dc is an interesting choice it weakens
both players pawn structure it opens up that
potential avenue of trade on the the d file
i think it's about equal i mean i would take
probably white here because of the disparity
in the bishop placement uh so i i don't know
i mean you have to decide what you take on c4
with first of all bishop takes seems a little
bit more natural to eliminate that tension but i
could see a case being made with for bc because
later on white's bishop if you eliminate the
pressure on the c4 pawn white's bishop could land
on f3 and he does exactly that again though we
see sir not jumping out to the early lead on time
and actually not sure i like the decision to keep
queens on the board for black you mentioned the
c4 pawn and if that gets defended the bishop can
leave e2 and it's easier to protect c4 with the
queens on the board it's easier to protect
the b2 bishop with the queens on the board
and i just feel like with white having a slight
spatial edge thanks to this pawn on c4 it could
go very well a3 now will kick the rook back but
that leaves the b3 square more vulnerable to the
touch and also the a3 pawn itself it's going
to be a bit more weak very very true here and
uh i don't know how this should go but i'm looking
eventually for like a bishop d3 but this is not
i mean i don't like well he wants i mean bishop c3
is of course the threat but it just seems a little
bit too artificial yeah queen a4 is what i'd
play here trade the queens off also queen takes
a2 there's rook a1 that's another trap but yeah a4
exactly 1a6 is hanging so he couldn't even take on
a2 i wasn't even looking down there i figured that
it was immune to capture if uh savion is giving up
the pawn like don't take it and now we're back
here with a c4 pawn is still weak as i mentioned
the queen trait should favor black b2 is something
that is harder to defend the c4 pawn as well
and there should be three is possible here trying
to liquidate and then take on taking on b1 with
the knight but that's a move you play if you're
just shooting for equality and you're trying to
bail out right because the end of it then the
black knight come to e4 the rook on the b8 or d8
you pick a file of your choosing so it's a way
for white to defend and he actually does this
good call danya and i do think that black should
be the preferred side rook d8 is rook d one rupee
but i think that sarno has no problem here
whatsoever right no i mean he he's he has
the choice here now one thing to don't get the
king to d6 here because of c5 nice that's a one
way to blunders if it's a check or don't play
knight b6 because knight b6 is still c5 there is
now c5 knight takes c5 defends the bishop so
they see these things they eat these things
for breakfast i mean they do not miss these kinds
of moves okay i don't want to jinx them but don't
miss these kinds of moves and king c5 is possible
but king c3 knight b6 knight d2 so oh my god mate
yeah that's what i'm going for honestly i'm
trying to defend the pawn and go for a checkmate
he plays c5 which i think is smarter and yeah
i was gonna say i was gonna show that mate on
the board because it's funny it is here knight
v6 knight d2 94 is checkmate maybe three also
would win a piece with c5 check so that would be
that's teenagers so knight b6 would be a really
good move is what you're saying it was just
an excellent move in that position for sure
okay so there is one thing that obviously
symbolically i think black is the one with
the pole because of his pressure on c4 but it
is so insignificant because white has allocated
all of his resources and actually don't laugh
but eventually if white reroutes his knight
to c3 via b1 and he goes a4 a5 potentially the
move knight b5 could be a little bit unpleasant
i don't think any of this is gonna happen i'm
just saying black can't fall asleep here either
certainly not and what black can do is think about
pushing some pawns in the king side but that also
has risks in and of itself because if you push
your pawns they may become more susceptible to
being attacked and that's why sauron puts his
bishop on c6 covering that b5 squares please go
knight b5 win my pawn a7 i'll actually not gonna
lie that i'll take you and then the it'll be a
favorable transition at least right so they're
maneuvering uh there is there is some life again
okay that comes back to me probably to d2 to just
secure everything a little bit more um solidly
is segment regretting that move h4 well i don't
think that sarnath has the resources to make him
regret it yeah because you put two attackers in
f3 it just quickly put two defenders there okay
knight f6 knight h5 i like this g5 coming okay
i do think seven should have just you know if
it ain't broke don't fix it i don't think you
should have moved anything on the king's side
and actually if you take on c6 does that help
white or black because the knight versus bishop
dynamic can be hard to assess he instead allows
the knight to come right back to d2 tonight is
jumping around constantly and it's hard
to deal with with no time on the clock
true i didn't even look at the clock savion once
again down a lot of time he's down a minute and
here we see g5 played and is the king coming to
e5 is the knight coming e5 well now neither is
and g4 play watch out for this knight come to
h5 and knight f1 bishop g2 savion tries to net
that in the bud but knight d4 that's
a big square i guess it's a fortress
you know who doesn't believe in fortresses
uh bishop f3 oh bishop three that's a sneaky
move but king b6 trying to go king a5
wow this knight shift can jump to a4
okay here comes the bishop oh oh king a5
knight b3 though i think that force is a draw
right so the knights get traded then there
is a fortress because you can't attack a
dark square palm with a white square fish
how do you even get to h5 you need to get
to g7 to get to h5 i don't think there's
a mathematical way to do that amazing
that is i'm looking it's actually really funny oh
there no there literally isn't a way to get to h5
no there's not you need to get the g7 which is
v e8 but there's no way to get to what knight c6
knight b6 98 96 98 97 98 you get the point oh my
god it's the most epic plan of all time watch him
do it though he has all the time in the world and
at the end of that white just plays knight f1 and
offers a draw true but i hope he goes for it just
to show you that it is possible right miracles i
think he is i think he's going to go for it and
and at the end of knight f1 they're going to make
a draw yeah and there's no nothing that white
can backwards because you have these pawns under
control you can't even attack e6 ever right i mean
this is always you're you're kind of your hand
is shaking here it's unpleasant to defend this
but if you just stay vigilant and there he goes
well he's wait where is it going again he needs
to go to a8 to c7 to uh e8 to g7 hilarious
so yeah he needs to get this knight to a8 bam so
he'll have to play knight b8 d7 move the king over
so that's like the longest plan in the history of
endgames and it would just allow white to make an
immediate draw so it doesn't work yeah and well
he plays a5 okay that doesn't actually do much
it gives you the a6 square so you can go to e8
i think he's trying to lull sevien
to sleep and now he's going to
mount that maneuver mark my words he's going
to go night before night a6 he actually he
does the night before so excuse me those words
have been marked but now what do i do with them
you i have a couple of things you can do with them
but i will not i will share that during the break
oh you're just the most polite coconut
immaculately polite and we have another
bononi sevien probably has some fond memories of
the result of the last bononi but likely not the
position that he is yeah nobody doesn't want to
get that allow saranac to have that pawn again
on d5 what do you think robert well it's uh here
comes bishop f4 looking like it increasingly now
one thing that i was taught a long time
ago if maybe this is completely out of
touch with reality but if black has to put a
queen on e7 and the bononi that usually means
that well because the possibility of e5 now is
essentially forcing black's hand so that is why
cevian acquiesced to knight e5 maybe knight h5 and
then knight e5 oh he does it again i can't believe
it but that was a really really bad position yeah
i don't enjoy this at all and he spent time to get
the same position so i don't think he trusts it
either when you spend 30 seconds your opponent is
moving just instantly every single turn and then
you have the same position that we didn't like
and bishop g4 so something about it saranac didn't
like either but are you inviting f5 at some point
oh okay queen g5 watch out for your g2 oh i think
that what this is wait but ef yeah what is this
now let me tell you one thing i think that what
sevien is doing is a conscious psychological
ploy he knows that the position is bad he knows
what if sarnath fails to win this again and it
increasingly is looking like black is recovering
again he is going to be particularly frustrated so
it's a gamble but i think it just might pay off
i'm with you because right now i don't see how
white's pawns are moving forward and i do see a
potential for h5 queen h4 g5 g4 sounds like i mean
b5 it's like everywhere about all
of a sudden black is the one with
an advantage maybe white should just play
d6 knight d5 but i don't buy that either
that could just lose your d-pawn yeah well it
will i was just thinking of putting that on d5
but that alone that doesn't give much right oh
man so what else can white do here queen to e2
to attack a6 comes to mind because you want to
provoke a5 that seems to give me the b5 square
i won't complain about that right i mean perhaps
you yeah rook cto is going to propose liberating
knight b1 knight a3 is an idea queen e2 would have
been a big blunder just to show that oh nice it
would have watched an f3 pin here checkman g2 for
hanging on d2 as well so don't that question oh
f3 like in second and go rook f6 you can that's
it probably not smart i could go rook f6 and
probably force the queen back to f3 right because
rook f6 is pawn f3 then you're giving up all the
dark squares okay now no still probably not enough
what about queens for g5 g4 how are you going to
stop me mm-hmm 92 knights you won but then i go g4
when your knight is on g1 it doesn't make it to f3
yeah it doesn't look like it's good enough
yes knight needs to move up the square to c4
right and the a6 pawn is hanging over here
so that's something that uh you have to
keep some attention to if there's rook to be a
don't take on a6 there's pawn f3 that right that's
a vicious vicious little tactic maybe there's also
just go f3 f3 then you're inviting your eventually
that's true i was just gonna say you take a
gamble and you just try to go for the queen side
but no that's not going to pay off and i wonder if
black's trying to go b5 himself yeah he definitely
is and the time is the only thing in serrano's
favor that he can try to harness if he can make
this complicated then his time advantage may make
its presence f3 is possible here because that f2
pawn might fall okay so he does that maneuver i
like it bringing the knight into f3 you called it
and c4 is possible for black gaining some space he
does it even knight f3 here should be considered
yeah queen takes g2 no because king g2 and then
bishop e5 falls at the end of the variation good
thing sam didn't pre-move something expecting
the queen to move we need three now i would
like invite the pawns forward okay queen e2 also
makes sense stopping v4 and this queen can replace
the bishop and it's still a blockade for black and
this e4 pawn down here we haven't highlighted that
you can play f3 as we've talked about in other
variations but then the dark squares are still
under black's control despite the fact that
bishop was traded off right and um okay so
again i think sir and i can take on e5 at his
leisure i think that he's wait now i think that
sam has sort of underestimated this maneuver over
the knights f3 look at this if rook v8 rook takes
c4 has to be dealt with right because the rook
is hanging on v8 and this is precisely what i
think we noticed about the clock now seven has to
burn into his reserves to deal with these threats
he's under 30 seconds this has taken a turn for
the worse for black yeah because you can just
take on e5 and then take on c4 but the e4 pawn is
hanging at the end however this d-pawn is trying
to run so he plays queen c5 going right after the
rook on b6 knight takes e5's a thread he goes rook
to v8 to protect everything including the b5 pawn
and this is just one of those positions where it
feels like white should be better but proving it
is immensely difficult you try to play d6 wait
wait is b2 hanging it is but then d6 i think
and then c3 like who's pawn i think he blundered
it but he's gonna pretend it's a sacrifice
it turns out to probably not be so bad no
i don't think it's great but i think
if e5 and maybe you sack on okay
oh i would be scared to play that movie because c2
yeah what is going on here and there's e5 e6 ideas
the bishop is cut out from the protection of the
king on g7 but knight d4 is also in the mix yeah
e6 i would consider and then just play knight
t4 after that yeah e6 looks pretty dangerous
or knight g5 because you just leave the rook
on d5 because of the fork on e6 i think we're
calculating it with playing e6 and the d6 pawn
becomes weaker knight five yeah the knight g5
queen d7 is like a desperate enemies of queen
c7 for white you just have to consider all these
possibilities and rookie one okay he gives a check
but queen f6 what is his idea yeah there's also c2
coming whoa and they've broken d5s hangings that
was a terrible move i think that was a really bad
that was this horrible move did we have he had
plenty of time on his plug yeah that was not good
i don't have an explanation for that queen no
that was that was a hallucination i think he
thought the king had to move and he saw something
got excited even if the king moved though i mean
black had c2 he walked right into the uh x-ray
of the bishop and that was just losing donna
you missed it but savion took a sip of water
there no i'm saying the peter gionata's theorem
it has been mathematically proven to
be it has c2 oh yeah it's just wait
oh i thought there was some
mating ideas but no no king h6
there's no even knight f6 because i got the h4 and
he's four knight g5 pre-moved forward age seven
yeah oh look at that he didn't
even get a queen so let me try
that so i get this queen here he's saying no no
no no no no i don't see any of that this is just
that is a blow if sebian can take this home
uh that is a big blow to end the three-minute
portion the lead will still be at two points
that is exactly i believe where they started
no no it won't be it won't be two points
will be even oh yeah sorry it's the other one
yeah you know we're going
to have a thriller in the
stalemate oh that was close that was close
rook h8 check go for the sacrificial he sees
it and he knows it and he is very precise
here serrano's trying for stalemate but
hey kg4 just play king g4 you're attacking
the rook you're threading bishop g3
resigns it is in deep tied robert we kind of could
sense it this was going to be the closest match
yet guess what well it has delivered that was
some incredible action in the three-minute portion
it certainly was and for sarina he's probably
quite frustrated with himself because he had
a lead throughout this match and now it's tied
heading to the bullet where it's really a toss-up
because even if one player is higher rated unless
it's a huge disparity like we saw nihal sauron win
yesterday against anton smirnov it's anybody's
match at this point it is and we will catch our
breaths and when we return 30 minutes of one plus
one buckle up we'll be back shortly everybody
so
and we returned ready for the bullet portion of
what has been a stellar match up to evenly matched
players sam savion and alexis serrano before the
match even began dania we saw that the predictions
it was as pretty much as close as it gets
fifty-five percent odds in sevien's favor
forty-five percent for sarana dania we're in
the bullet now what do you think indeed and the
smarter chess prediction has has been the case
very often it has been right on the money and
well it predicts a very close a bullet segment i
think that's to be expected now we've seen in in
the previous we've seen some close matches decided
by the bullet but we've seen a lot of cases where
one player basically just runs away with it in
the first couple of games um i dare say i don't
think that's going to happen here i mean these
players have been so close and the games have
been so tightly contested i don't see a reason why
one player should run away with it but obviously
you'd never know what do you think yeah it's tough
to say with these two competitors because they've
been evenly matched throughout sarah not had a
lead seven came back just now so seven probably
is feeling good about himself at least relative
to what he was feeling a little while ago and
in bullet especially with the increment that makes
all the difference and serrano has been faster but
sevien has proven mighty in the last bunch look
at their ratings by the way they're about the same
yeah and uh we'll see i mean those benoni games
uh it's important for sardot to to make sure
they don't get under his skin uh that he sort of
resets and we do have uh another night off here
which of course is right in alexis wheelhouse
but probably sam as has been the case has
prepared certain openings specifically
for the bullet and watch over bishop
f3 isn't it just wait a second no no this is
97 queen d5 check uh there has been probably
there's like a queen trap there i mean there's
definitely alexi knows this um you sure buddy
yes i mean these are like known tactics when you
can't take on e4 because of the light squares and
yeah shannon hasn't really moved from his stance
but he's not only that this reminds me of an
i'll get moderate video and of course
best wishes to to agamatter who
it appears that that his heart surgery
went well so prayers and and support
to to him but there was a funny video he shared
in one of his games where he blundered a rook
in exactly this fashion and he pulled this stunt
where he he was pretending that he had something
up his sleeve uh but in reality he wanted to
resign and his opponent believed him but here
there was enough just nothing at all no this is
a clean extra rook for sevien and as you said we
wish antonio our very best and hope that he has a
smooth recovery hello everyone let's wish him the
best and uh hopefully he'll be back making
videos soon but for now if you're a alexis
serrano fan you better hope that he's going to
rebound fast because there's not that much time
left 28 minutes all of it's going to be bullet
and look at this we have the budapest from sevien
i was going to make a pond with antonio's last
name rad i was going to say it was a radical
development but oh yeah that is a blow right
there in the early going as budapest indeed that
is a bullet opening if i've ever seen now it's not
actually robert objectively it's not that bad like
it's at best i think white gets a slight advantage
which he has done yeah you're right though because
black has the typical uh access to the a file the
bishop on b7 looks very good there's no d-pawn to
go d5 and shut down that bishop from b7 but for
now i would say that white is slightly better
but black is hanging there just fine indeed
and uh well c5 c5 exactly trying to chip away
no i think it should be in the realm of a
draw but these these positions are so hard
to play with the bullet but look at the times
they both have a minute remaining essentially
what about 94 yeah just try to bail out a
nice e3 oh nice yeah i'm also trying to take
on g3 like everything is sort of hanging
in white's position even if you win a pawn
your pawn structure will be shattered so knight
e4 i'm looking at c takes d6 knight takes g3 here
and you have to take back with the fball and
he's taking his time with he has left himself
a good amount of time to calculate he knows that
if indeed this is a draw he's going to be able
to survive but he's got to move relatively fast i
mean with 10 seconds that's going to be quite hard
yes okay he doesn't take on c5 like about it
i don't know now he's definitely it should be
still a draw but okay i mean i think here
the realistic practical chances are higher
okay oh and now with the double pawns the
c5 pawn is it a strength is it a liability
i don't like what sarna just did there because
those pawns and i mentioned this yesterday can
actually be an asset i know it sounds ridiculous
that even if black trades bishops it gives up c5
that is almost impossible to win because
those pawns act kind of like a sponge
they soft up any attempts that white may have
at pushing his own pawns if that makes sense
not to say that he's going to give up
he's not even going to give up c5 easily
i thought there's no king a4 there but
he didn't want to get his king cut off
that's a nice idea look at f4 rook at 5 as
possible you play e4 and g4 and bring the
rook into f5 right and that's not to say winning
attempts are not possible with those pawns but
it's not like completely winning for white it's
what i'm saying and this rook can go back and
forth along the back rank here putting pressure
on g2 protecting ponzi 5 here goes rook to g8
rookie 5
oh that's also looking good so he gives
the rookie four off from the trade
field agree accuracy by sarah not just
not allowing any of these attempts
i mean this is a very creative defensive
it's what you said even if you lose the c
pawn this is still looking like a theoretically
drawn alex alex your malinsky taught me this in
a lesson i had with him years and years ago and i
never forgot this he's like those pawns they can
be the greatest defensive asset in a three-on-four
end game he didn't say it exactly like that
every russian school boy goes that supports
that looks the ugliest in fact supposed
and these pawns are doing just that you know it's
funny how does white even win this game king of
five f4 somehow you know what you're doing you
play the the classic bullet rook b5 or kc3 or k3
they try to make the rook and get onto but
that's where the increment eliminates this
kind of plane but this is not a serious attempt i
mean he's doing what he can of course as he should
but there's no way to make progress and what i
mean you can see here very clearly how the pawns
exactly they're like spikes burying that
vampire although if you were anton smyrnov
you would have really traumatic recollections
of this position because he was up upon
and he lost on time against nihal sarin yesterday
but this is just easy for black to hold you keep
your rook behind the pawns if a pawn's ever
traded then it just there's no winning chances
we've been there before right with the brook and
f5 so king h6 i don't know about i guess rook f3
whoa now he might have screwed this up
that's possible because you're trained rookie
keep your rook behind the pawn you should not
have gone to h6 i'm with you that looks really
bad actually yes now wait a second wait a
second for sure back to wait 7.3 seconds
there's rookie for some yeah seven it's winning
which is unbelievable oh my gosh unbelievable
we've seen this one several times don't play e6
rook g2 is good the king is cut off you're gonna
push your pawn and then it's just an easy lucina
well you don't even need the lasagna position
how how did this happen he had everything under
control it's just what it shows is that in working
there's always going to be that one attempt and
here it is indeed the classic lucena position
you build a bridge and serrano probably
learned this before he learned how to walk
here's the bridge he makes it he promotes
the pawn and that is why we saw resignation
we have a tied match once again we
do and that was incredible i mean
he found he squeezed the life out of
the position found what he needed to
find and that critical mistake thinking
that the game is already over what whoa
what did you see what just happened there no
i wasn't i wasn't looking yeah look at that
that was a jaba london and sevien played
92 and then knight back to g1 around to f3
what is that typical at all no i mean i
not saying an authority on the subject even though
i've played the java wonder for you for years i've
never seen that before it makes some sense i mean
the thing with the java is it's not like in these
positions every tempo is crucial right that's true
because the position remains closed for a bit and
so there's no like quick attack or anything of the
swords right now better white is definitely better
you control the c file you also have a
pawn majority on the queen side over here
and black's pawns don't get to mobilize very
easily you can't push e5 without between d5
you push d4 i take you you're left with double
isolated pawns okay this is a good explanation
maybe defense okay but this is just looking
terrible i mean look at the crunch that we saw
a game like this a little bit earlier i think it
was sevien who was also the one dominating that
queen side we see something similar here
it's not about winning a particular pawn
it's just black's position as a whole that is
not really holding together although i like what
sarna is doing trying to trade as many pieces as
possible intercepting the c file this is serious
progress now in the defensive end oh yeah because
now black's funds can actually push e5 d4 and
whose pawns are better play e5 king f7 latch is
much better now it shows you in the bullet things
can turn around in the snap of a finger you miss
one opportunity to make progress boom table's turn
and all right so here the bishop on c4 is just
better than the counterpart on d1 the bishop one
g3 stuck to the defense of this pawn h4 black
with plenty of time hitting now the b4 pawn
okay so is that a i guess you have enough to
hold the balance there well it depends there's
a lot of tactical ideas in this specific
queen h7 though because 557 is between f5
indeed indeed he's got to go queen c8 i think
right because if you get your queen trapped
over here and then the black queen could trade it
off that looks like a losing attempt rather than
winning his abs oh wait no he's doing it but queen
f8 sees something and then there's queen champion
maybe g4 at the end but there's just queen g8
takes and takes and takes i guess the pawn is
hanging there i do agree with you though e5 or
a5 can be considered in some positions to fix
that font on a4 but quinje is the only move
because if you take on g4 threats of bishop
takes e6 with check dislodging the king from the
defense of anything on g7 exactly no you have to
do it i don't know why he's taking so long um if
he doesn't do it he's just probably gonna get in
huge trouble i yeah i just failed to see what else
there is and now we see this end game or why does
the outside passer but as you correctly pointed
out robert that pawn mass is serious longer as
material it really is d3 bishop a2 bishop b1
bishop c2 that's a god long way to go but that's
a possibility but also look at the pawn on a6 you
point these things out bishop g4 bishop ca that
might create all of a sudden very unpleasant uh uh
circumstances for black okay to b3 bishop g8 would
help the pawn push but you have to watch out for
the d-pawn uh-oh who's bonus faster king g5 mg5
oh no and now white f4 check probably he has to
play no but there was amphison and like oh sarah
bishop h5 wrong color pawn wrong pawn it's a draw
wrong you just keep the king there you don't get
the king out amazing yeah this is the draw and we
should remind everybody as this game was drawn the
match is still level at this point that if at
the end of this bullet portion it is a tie we
will have an additional four one minute plus one
second increment games to try to break the tie
and if that little mini match is tied we get
to armageddon where white block five minutes
black will have three minutes and black gets
draw odds a distinct possibility robert but
we haven't seen a match this close we've seen
close matches this is literally down to the wire
oh yeah what a save that was from both players
it looked like uh sarana was taking the advantage
and then all of a sudden seven had some chances
and then seven realized okay the wrong caller
uh with the coin oh knight d5 sorry sorry
interrupts you no no you're good interrupt
there's tactics on the board and now uh savings
up a pawn in e4 this is not winning of course but
here c6 has to be prepared quickly he has to get
the center open move the rook a6 and c6 sarah is
doing a great job here limiting that potential
you might laugh donya i think practically it's
easier for white to play no i would be frightened
completely agree because i think he had that one
opportunity he has to prevent i i like bishop c6
though but look at him trying to prevent it a4
the knight can come to c5 if you're not getting it
you have to be careful about that right so bishop
so so we're not showing indications that
he's going to attack also on the king side
potentially with g4 that's a good point and that
could backfire because it may weaken your own king
but for now you can put his queen on c6 oh but
then where's that queen going uh oh oh my gosh
but then okay seven yeah the you know rookie seven
after rookie eight and what okay knight c5 i mean
that's not the end of the movie takes you back
to get the queen out queen i'm sick i don't think
this is that bad though just rook c7 what are
you gonna do knight queen f6 now yeah rook c7
is where i actually have some skits counter play
because queen takes b6 and i have before yeah
i don't know man i mean i mark my words see i've
already told you this once black is going to
get serious counterplay i'm not going to say
he's going to win okay this is not going to
be obvious there we go ooh g5 i like that move a
lot queen c6 hitting the rook on all right rookie
can i play just rookie i didn't like giving the
queen access here now f5 f5 is another option
oh you're right f5 now because i wonder knight
before fork drop stage g3 oh my gosh did you
mark my words i am i marked them down i am now
living them i'm seeing what's happening here b7
okay because queen a7 there's no threat b7 came
to play the queen is hanging on b7 it's still
possible to blunder we know how resilient is there
is there kind of a draw with queen d7 queen g4 no
the king just sits on h five maybe oh yeah yeah
but then i have queen h5 like do you actually
get out yeah yeah no i agree now he's going to c6
he's trying to create connected passers this is
27 grady 7 the rook's hanging but rook b8
and then king f8 so b7 if you move your queen
so queen a7 is queen g4 queen c8 back and forth
between d6 queen e6 is also hanging with e5 to
fall broke alexis knight f193 can i bring my
knight in or do i give you additional ideas
but does that allow checks that's what i'm worried
about oh my gosh so much is happening queen seven
you go free g5 also is a possibility okay but now
g1 is possible king c2 i guess watch out for queen
c8 so wait quincy it's a queen knight c4 who's
winning there take something 366. yeah knight c4
is coming okay but i thought maybe you could take
him going x4 but he wants to do it anyway queen e7
it's a repetition queen c7 27 keep the rook under
attack queen i would take and go knight c4 oh my
gosh taking knight c4 you win the d6 pawn by four
if that's not over because black has the h fun who
is winning there there might be a repetition
another draw king moves i suggest king moves
so he plays h4 knight c4 h3 the king and then the
queen comes to g5 i think black sacrifices on b8
and promotes oh man so king f1 h2 he doesn't so
66 took with the queen and now the knight comes
in and replaces the queen but then h2 wait take
any five oh you talk about that takes b7 could
you do an h2 queen about who's winning i think the
blacks twins you're getting the check game queen
with check unbelievable wins the night stops the
pawn that's unreal everything worked out perfectly
and if you are sarnat you resign stop playing this
game resign there he goes he does he's frustrated
but 15 minutes left on the match clock plenty of
time it's a one-point game but this is where you
have to stop the bleeding if you're alexi yes and
well where's the next game where's the next game
they gotta they gotta reaction it's not 15
minutes a bullet it's 30. yeah i don't know
what just happened but it's like 10 seconds
came off i think the server might have what my
no okay no it's not oh no it might be because
on my end it's glitching a little bit no i but
i see now all of a sudden sarna has full uh phil
and it's sevien who asked me but i think that was
both players temporarily yeah i see it right
now both players are connections are struggling
there indeed indeed something seems now's our
own eyes back but he's got 37 he's got to move
um i'm going to ask for confirmation
just to see what's happening
and it looks like uh uh
team is dealing with behind the scenes
seeing what's going on with the players
uh we will await their word but right now i mean
dania this has been as close of matches you could
ask for and the game was just cancelled okay so
the players uh will restart this and i'm sure the
time will be added back to the match clock and uh
that way it's all fair so it seems like it was a
mutual problem not just one player maybe
it was a quick little sort of reboot but
hopefully we get the games going very shortly
here and players still seated getting ready for
the next game indeed indeed and uh yeah this
happens but robert i need to catch my breath
there's some of my friends watching the match
texted me about this game that was crazy
and yeah i mean this this has been crazy it
looks like that players are in communication
with the team who's doing such a great job behind
the scenes making sure that everything's okay and
we do have liftoff so that was a very interesting
quick fix thank you um mira jake pick everybody
who's helping out thank you so much for that and
we do have the next game everything seems to be
right and we have a fiance so a slower approach
from sevien from an opening standpoint but he does
have a one game lead indeed and i also have
to add my shout out such a professional job
always done by the people behind the scenes
we'll thank them properly at the end but
uh this would all not be possible without them
okay so yeah i like white's position here because
of the c5 square there is a lack of equivalency
between the c5 score on the one hand but the c4
square is not accessible obviously because white
is upon on b3 i think white is a slight pull
but it's not that significant right because 93 is
play you do not want to allow a trade with a side
that's slightly less space in this case it's black
with a bit less space and you want to somehow get
your c3 knight to c5 so do not play b4 if you're
black that'd just well now you might play b4 whoa
got to watch out but i think that
giving the a4 then c5 square is
not advisable so on the other hand black
has more space this is this position
that's the thing and look at that diagonal
the bishop has left the long diagonal
so black has to record with that this should be
five so bishop b5 you still can't take next the
rook is hanging though it's close and he plays
knight look at that he's like you can't take
me the knight on f6 is always hanging over
here knight f4 to d3 reinforce that pony
he takes on d7 that bit of a bailout no knight
d3 but why do you have to take on d7 can you
just bring the knight to d3 first right keep
the temperature now he's reorienting himself
toward the queen's head look at the c file though
it isn't under white's control because rook dixie
can be met with queen 62 so he's increasing the
pressure adding the tabasco sauce but is it enough
uh okay he's bringing the bishop in watch
out for a sack on e6 at the right moment
so that's why sauron brings the bishop to d6
another idea is to play at some point before all
of these central breaks but will they make them
happen or will white over extend himself he can
take on f4 and take on id you can and i'm looking
at rook c5 for white at some point not now of
course because the knight is hanging but you can
sacrifice look at the bishop on h3 watch out shoot
you cannot play knight d3 oh my gosh it's trapped
and you can't play that same reason how what do
you do do you take on e6 do you bite the bullet
he does take any six which is just pawn takes
six is lost no of course take on c1 play queen
eighty-eight queen eight and the queen e4 here
five hangs he did too much tabasco sauce and the
bishop's still trapped if it went over to uh h3
oh it ain't over till it's over g4
though carving out those light squares
yeah there's queens okay for anyway the c7 square
is covered queen f5 threatening queen of three you
go knight g4 he plays knight d5 you get the
blockade trade queens and win the game here
huge huge win uh robert and one felt that perhaps
you released the tattoo too early i felt like
seven had that chance with his knight on c5 you
called it i think he went in the wrong direction
there it is still a tight match with 11 minutes
to go we got a bangkok give it another change
i know savion likes this opening he's
been playing it since he was very young
he does indeed it's upon sacrifice but you get
such good piece play and in bullet in particular
that is good for the side that has the easier plan
so the pawn has been lost or sacrificed i should
say and uh there are just under 11 minutes on the
match like whoa knight g5 giving up the e6 pawn
now knight c7 played to defend that square is more
important to not allow the knight in taking this
bishop off the board indeed and um i this these
positions are as crazy as it gets the vanco has
become a little bit less popular recently but that
does not mean it's not a good bullet weapon but i
it does not seem like a good bullet weapon right
now look at what's happening to savion's position
i mean look at this bishop on seed 26 mate was a
threat so how many did you you don't have a pawn
for the exchanges looking into the top of the
center you're the center but you don't actually
have material for the exchange rights and these
are not saying ladies and gentlemen passport star
of the show red carpet unrolled a6 coming this
is looking very bad it certainly is and you know
now you can play queen into b5 but now you can't
because the pawn came to c4 but rook a4 hits the
c four pawn behind it is the d4 point both of
them are weak and if you ever play rook c8 well
thank you for removing your rook from the path of
my pawn indeed d3 queen g4 unsustainable is the
pawn motion for black because he just doesn't have
enough resources to hold everything together asics
convincing confidence and again the opening uh
prowess of not coming into play here even though
it's the bullet that extra edge robert in knowing
the opening knowing the theory now here still some
hurdles to cross that a4 rook is hanging and d1
is going to be hanging out for that that's true
because i want to play 26 check but i need to also
maybe play rook d1 to a1 i'm going to bring rook
a to a1 tough question do you want to double your
rooks behind the pawn he does so he can play a7 a8
and a7 yeah okay six rook a6 queen e6 check coming
yeah he's holding him down here and if you trade
queens you're just completely lost but then d2
i would argue that's not so simple i wouldn't be
able to six yet i would go yeah so centralization
hitting the d5 pawn you can also play rook a5 to
win d5 queen e4 creates a bit of a pawn diamond
there now you play slowly g3 or h3 i would just
throw that throw that in there so you don't have
to worry but bishop g7 needs to be reckoned with
as well he does do this because you pretend this
queen eve oh hangs the plane i'm trying to get my
queen of b8 but i can't even have f4 though your
idea is absolutely right yes so bishop g7 i move
my queen away bishop takes b2 you sack the other
rookie you bank on your pawns that doesn't work
though no because my queen on beat also takes
b2 back nice he doesn't play queen b6 is even
better can be seven yes queen b7 rook bc two and
you come around for the pawns he's gotta resign
and start the next game eight minutes same same
logic as the previous game rook d6 wins oh rook
d6 is so nice removing the guard of this rook on
eight and then you're getting your queen amazing
again here by seven and now the ball passed back
into sam's court he's trying everything he can
resigns eight minutes on the clock this is another
pivotal game robert as the lead shifts to alexis
sarina and sam actually seems very calm right now
maybe he's both convincing himself to be calm but
nerves must be real someone has to up a game right
now we have no ceiling this is going to get sharp
so lines like this the queen can often come to g3
but not so fast because knight h5 would hit the
queen on g3 and pawn f4 f5 now this could backfire
if black gets d5 and this is an old idea that
has been around a long time now if white can play
bishop g5 takes f6 and plan tonight on d5 a couple
of classical games have gone this way things
are very unpleasant to sir not understandably
but still look at that d5 square that is how
the battle is going to be decided oh my god
like what sam is doing queen g3 coming g5 the d4
pawns hanging as well whoa but bishop takes a 5.
oh bishop f5 was missed opportunity so f6 get
rid of that pawn don't hang on anymore bishop
cc again bishop f5 but there's the e5 pawn still
though i would do it again but d4 was hanging
earlier as well because the queen has not been
defended now look at the positional sack he's
going to plant a rook on him for a blockading
rook now he's going to redirect his attention
to the attack i don't see what saranac can do here
to throw water onto the fire right because you put
g6 in comes h5 h5 anyway look at how quickly seven
is playing this knight h4 knight five bring that
knight tightening the screws chiseling his way
inside the paint knight f5 and g6 even he takes
first because knight five knight h6 check or queen
f3 hitting up seven this is crushing absolutely
crushing and what a performance here by sebby and
tying the match it seems but let's not jinx him
sorry not can generate chances in any position and
that was a must by sevien was blocking the light
squares he gave him a pawn but said the control
is good enough ooh f7 is under attack queen f3 or
g6 as you're saying look good he plays g6 i have
some slight concern if this rook on e7 you can
come to g7 or h completely echoed yeah agreed but
i think it's a case where all roads lead to rome
yeah knight f7 check always available oh my gosh
and you take an h7 with check rook h4 rookie chain
mate it's just very forcing sequence no you did if
you play rook g7 knight of seven check knife sound
still just throw that pony in there mm-hmm g takes
and then rook g4 rook g8 thank you yeah gamer gp4
it's made for queen h6 is a symbolic check okay
okay well you can't i'm not sure about this one
rookie five yeah i think you're pretty sure now
aren't you yeah i'm pretty sure i was always sure
you have a problem being sure do we need to
replace the commentator here in the last five
minutes we might because it's just this is really
riling me up yeah it seems that we have quite the
argument here i mean this is ridiculous and if
you're seven you tie the match up if you are
sarina you're looking at the match clock probably
not right now because you're in the middle of a
pretty good no he's looking he's old he's not even
looking at the position but i'm looking at it so
five minutes remaining and if you're sarina like
this is going back and forth at this point how
are you feeling after a loss it's like you know
it reminds me of and i've made some comparisons
to basketball but you know that situation when you
go for what's called a two-for-one 30 seconds left
in the game and the match is how you throw up a
shot so that you will have at least another one
guaranteed now this is actually getting a little
bit interesting here i think the eight pawn is too
fast yeah five and one oh wait go can use three
first one nice move because that's pissing you
do not want to allow rook check so then the punch
goes a6 rook takes d6 is the threat with the 8466
don't play a7 which is still winning 66. so
now there are at least i think two more games
guaranteed right how does sarna play this i
don't think he plays it he plays it like a
regular game he's not trying to play particularly
fast but robert we've seen these players they have
just naturally played very very fast and very
confidently which is crazy and i just love this
image they're going back and forth as you see
with the dancing heads and this this line with
a c7 pawn is captured once again black and this
is sam sebian gets the activity for the material
and there is a game i still always forget was it
nakamura versus caruana it might have been carlson
i don't remember who i think all of them have
played this yeah it just it's a pawn sacrifice
where you take on f1 the king has to take and
then you can bring your rooks to the c files
i think i'm more nervous than the players or
my heart is beating right now i feel like i'm
entering a final exam in college or something
this is this is what we came here for
three wait a second that rook might be trapped
there's rook to be five back so you guys
okay so this is a little bit raj now who's better
in this situation i like the knight i like white
central control but i don't think the advantage
is particularly significant if it exists at all
well this this pawn a3 was hanging
it was rook a1 rook takes a7 so just
returning uh that pawn so that's why he didn't
do it and this position is definitely better for
white you have a knight and a light square can't
be attacked before d5 some type of ideas you have
a5 i think i just heard you say that and this is
just favorable for sauron for sure you can push
and look at the time speed this is hard to defend
he makes progress first he's got to watch out
f5 is an idea no this is actually looking really
really bad for black i didn't even realize the
extent of it over now but he kicks the rook away
and he's going to take on f5 and play g6 and
ah trade some pieces here he comes nice good
call he takes an e4 though oh i didn't like
that move because the jeep cemented oh gosh here
comes the knights of the d5 square still b4 and
bishop d6 how exactly does white make frog
you put the bishop on e6 first more flexible
okay so i'm looking at an eventual rook to
g1 not yet doesn't do too much of anything
but kd7 maybe then a rook g1 and then 95 threatens
the f6 pawn because the g dude okay okay so he's
trying to open up that ankle gearing himself
up he closes it back down but the c4 square is
weak and the knight can come there because he's
pushing that pawn forward i would say don't play
a5 because the knight would come right to c4
to attack it and he's trying to get the eight
king c3 threat big threat rook b5 rugby five
that way bishop before check and to win this
bishop before he misses it he's gotta go back and
now bishop a5 that might be a five i think you're
holding i think you're holding you are you are
you are and white's still better even there but
i think the black king just goes right back to
f8 and once it gets there it protects g7 he goes
now pawn end game could be trouble because e5
e60 is a protected password he doesn't do it he
shines away afterwards he's six look at that move
he's trying to open the fifth rank for the rook
over to h5 that's a good idea and now it's time
to make take and kick through what do you do
before checking it yeah yeah yeah go back and
the one thing i'm curious about is is there
a time that rook g1 try to get the g6 pawn two
okay you use the king to stop the pawn the rook
to attack but you can't take on g6 just yet right
because then you played b2 so you have to do that
for f5 maybe you do something there's one tempo
you have you always have king eight there you go
three you go to f7 to protect the pawn very deep
and you call the king c3 okay bishop b4 and bishop
c5 what a catch you could actually still do it
and go 96 at the end but the rook is protected
right so king b3 bishop c5 check it back king
b2 looks like the only move he goes king d3
so maybe net wasn't the only move but it worries
me to move away from that pawn minute they're
gonna have one more game probably after this
one how will this game end they're shuffling
their pieces around this game might not end for a
minute actually so this is gonna be our last game
rook g2 hitting the g6 pawn don't take it because
b2 bishop before check now king b3 how he takes oh
the g66 is gonna fall f5 play a five at some
point play f5 he's gonna watch the clock two
he's gotta resign if this gets lost yes he does he
knows 38 seconds left oh and now we'll fork on b7
is a threat the rooks you want great move okay
seven bishop g3 at some point i don't know when
um where are you six now this is a push
i would actually consider resigning this
i would consider it as well 25 seconds left
bishop g3 played knight of 70 goes back to
four rook c three she keep challenging he hasn't
got to be aware of the clock he's gotta resign it
and he's gotta resign it rook takes up
six it's another point if that's on five
there's twelve seconds left he doesn't see the
clock the rookie six assists a drives us a win
and he's got one second he barely gets resigned
he's got to resign inside he's got himself
beside he didn't he didn't he resigned he
gets one more game with two seconds oh my gosh
oh my god i've never been so happy to see somebody
resign in my life in a game that's not my own so
we have the sicilian once again it was uh seven
who played a great game pushes the pawn to f5 same
exact variation sarnath thinks it plays d5 but is
that good take on d3 this time is it good because
their e5 pawn is hanging as well so this is a i
think ed is is a move here and then the e5 hangs
but you get liquidation there he has to win this
game he's down by a point this is the last one
okay so he the e51 is falling and then when
the e5 falls the bishop 105 is under attack
so knight takes e5 wait why isn't this just an
extra pawn it is bishop f4 but okay the pawns
are weak bishop d6 is an idea but there's a big
initiative on top of the pawn white has to keep
this initiative stoked d4 to keep the knight
supported what will he do here d4 looks good
okay i was thinking just taking on g6 but he
wants to keep that knight in the center make sense
bishop can't move because he needs to protect the
f6 knight and queen d6 played do i take on g6 c4
do i take him fill the square with
my queen on e5 like can i replace it
in that maybe you do yeah nice using 3d5 i quite
like that but knight 65 at the end there's no
no but there's 97 to 4. oh i had that covered you
know you've been great with the tags today but
every now and then i got this the knight is
pinned f7 is falling okay this is very hard to
play robert with the black piece but look at the
time 15 seconds extra for starting up that could
make its presence felt yeah and i'm going to give
you that oh knight g4 takes it but just taking
this is the last game he knows that he's trying
to figure this out rookie one okay i like that
you didn't have to rush back to e5 and that way
the bishop cannot get to f6 i like to move the
knights here are there's so many outposts the c6
were created a3 stopping before oh now knight's
coming to c6 is not because bishop f6 knight c6
there we go and they're not holding it together
can you choose to trade rooks on e8 and then play
rookie one i don't see a way to make progress
yeah i think you have to do they have to fight for
the e file that's what he does he wants to double
yeah so what's happening here hmm okay he does
double he gets the e5 but sarna creates that hole
for the king on h7 but there's a 97 at some point
not now because rook to e8 but that's what the
king went to h7 and here we look at the position
white is much better here he is h3 prudent but
he creates a weakness on g3 there is a downside to
it oh he trades the bishop system that's important
that's important this he's making progress so
he's protecting the d5 pawn with look at five but
you don't even need to because there's no way to
double on the pawn the knight c6 is too powerful
i like this move rook f3 you can
play g4 king g2 if you want or g3 kg2
yeah so okay what now queen if i love that move
off for the queen's raid okay he doesn't want to
give the e8 good move keeping control of the files
95 shifting it around f7 under pressure knight g4
is an idea here rook c3 coming to c6 to the right
spots rook c5 good move look at the protected
rookie eight by starting out rookie eight rook
c6 so rookie six anyway because you're gaining
ground 25 is also very good looks good trade the
rise oh i thought you'd trade the rooks there
now this is dangerous the bishop h4 something like
that i think white's king is weak he has to give
another king knight back to e5 okay queen of four
i don't like the retreat but maybe he felt he was
necessary or not five seconds oh my gosh this
is tough quincy seven no doesn't attack anything
rook c7 there's no threat oh that's such an
important one it's a huge blow bishop takes
d4 straight queens ah it doesn't look good for
him no it's still i think he's maintaining some
pressure 26 now of course okay but look at that at
five squared is that significant taking c4 though
i don't see it happening no because when you take
nd4 the rook takes with check four but the knight
can wherever there is tonight there are chances
but are not defending so well here you need the
knight to come to f5 right somehow he brings
his knight to h2 knight g4 bishop b2 and then
jumping to e3 out of five scores we got five check
though f5 check oh he can't take it because rookie
six and so on this is a huge blow this is looking
very tough now for seven he needs to win this game
and how is he going to win this does now he's
going back to that one only by a four rookie
one is possible at some point actually there's
nowhere to go yeah so rookie one looks very good
93 oh king c3 trying to trap the knight but back
to oh look at that he realized the king on the c
file no longer the rook on say it hits the c
one square he's trying desperately knight of
four check don't fall for that though knight d4
rook c6 okay he run rook f6 so he saw that you
got to keep trying here if you're seven you got
to keep the knight preserve then f4 f4 and f3
and you're just gonna force a trade here knight
f4 you were looking at rook j from g6 but bishop
very important that's basically it this is it
that's it you've got to try something like rook
there's just no way to lose this if security
there is no winner loses yeah you don't want to
too much time play for k6 you know just hope for
the pre-move mm-hmm no you have to try that but
yeah it's got to take on b3 but
but no it's over g2 and this is
look at him pumped up as he should be
the clutch game with black and what an
effort by sevi an amazing job and the presence
of mind to resign i know this sounds ridiculous
and then a fantastic effort and it came down right
to the why what a match what the match there are
so many brilliant moves over the board but the
resignation was maybe the most of all realizing
it with just two seconds in the clock but all
credit to alexis serena for winning this match
it was so back and forth nerves must have been
just like overwhelming and yet he did keep his
composure in the end he wins the match thirteen
nine and eleven half we're going to take a short
technological recess because when we come
back we will be joined by the players for
a post-match interview i am so looking
forward to hearing their thoughts because
there's just so many jitters we'll
be right back everybody stay tuned
and after an exhilarating finish we are
joined by the players first and foremost
alexa huge congratulations i have to ask you how
nervous were you down the stretch of the match
okay thank you very much
it was really nervous much
because i think i played this much really good
but sometimes and i i was really good preparing
in the opening and then i know something
happened in the time travels so and some
come back and in the bullet i just think that
i am big outsider so i'm really happy how
happens so i don't know well uh congratulations
alexa and sam that was a fantastic match
by you so many amazing games and you know
this may sound weird but we were actually
impressed with the presence of mind you had
in the penultimate game resigning it just as
the clock expired giving yourself one more game
were you sort of aware of that specifically and
on a more general note um what are your thoughts
about the match sort of what do you feel went well
what do you feel didn't go as well uh for the
first question i saw there was eight minutes
left and there are two games left and uh i
felt they have to resign as fast as possible
and for the match i mean he said he was very well
prepared especially in this nimzo e4 line he had
an idea in almost every game um yeah basically
what went wrong was in the bullet that binko
game i just lost really quickly and that was that
probably was the reason yeah that definitely makes
sense and you know you obviously had a good shot
even in the final game but in bullet anything can
happen uh well alexa it seemed like earlier
in the match things were starting to go your
way you're gaining some confidence but then you
know the match kept getting even when you had a
lead it then went to even so how did you keep your
composure and manage your way through that because
nerves and just the tension of winning and
losing it must get to you a little bit right
yes okay it's really hard
when you lost your leading
so i just i just play the game sometimes
i tilt it and but but i think i play
more i i was wasn't so tilted i i missed
i miscalculate not too much and i think so
and this was important that even if after loses
i miscalculate not some remaining beams yeah
well uh alexi before we we let uh you go
both of you go for it for a deserved rest
you're playing uh jeffrey zhang on sunday i'm
sure you're very well familiar with jeffrey uh
do you have any thoughts on on jeffrey and how
you might approach that coming oncoming match
okay in this tournament jeffrey is
the most higher rated player and
much more famous than others so i think that
his favorite of the tournament i don't know
what to do with him in the next match so i try
to try to play but i think his big favorite
wow but here but here he won matches not
so easily so maybe so everyone had chances
against him it's true and you're a very strong
player obviously and the modesty is certainly
noticed but uh alexa congratulations to you and
sam sorry that the match didn't go your way and
hope to see you maybe in the super swiss blitz
event tomorrow and throughout the weekend but uh
you know you did put up such a great showing and
it made for a very fun match well done both of you
and thanks to uh both of our players
for what was i mean honestly one of the
absolute most fun matches i've ever covered the
resignation with two seconds on the match clock
just prolonging it giving it another game and as
we see alexis serrano moves into the semifinals
he's so humble donya you just heard him there
he's like jeffrey's more famous he's well known
he's the big favorite but you know maybe i have
some chances some i think he has plenty of trouble
i mean i love that about all of these players is
how humble they are they let their moves do the
talking and uh they put such effort into each
and every match and definitely i think alexi
he definitely has a chance he he just played
some amazing chess we'll go back through the
games i'm sure he'll analyze them he'll prepare
we know about his opening preparation now that
is going to be a scintillating match but not to
downplay the effort of course of sam sevien who
put on a fantastic display and it literally
came down literally came down to the last second
it really did and for sam while his jscc run
comes to conclusion he has a chance to make the
speeches championship that is a huge goal for
all these players and the tournament begins
tomorrow with the speedchest super swiss have an
opportunity to make his way into the big sec where
you can play the likes of hikaru nakamura and easy
win fellow superstar grand masters i'm sure wesley
all of them will make their presence very much
felt in the speed chess championship but for now
donia we have four semi-finalists jeffrey zhang
takes on alexis serrano on the other side of the
bracket we will have nihal sarin taking on hike
marti rosian it's just so much fun is it not it's
every match the time just flies by these games
each and every one of them amazing action so
close so much tactics so much just tension and so
much effort so much preparation we've got all of
the ingredients of one amazing match after another
and uh these matches are good in and of themselves
but you know what makes them better for me
commentating with the likes of grand master robert
hess so it really always is a huge pleasure to
cover these matches with you as well as to cover
them alongside thousands of fans across various
platforms you know absolutely and we often joke at
each other's expense but honestly the hours flew
by today i'm looking at the clock on my computer
here i'm like whoa already we've been doing this
for almost four hours now but it's such a joy and
matches like that i mean we talked yesterday
the match-up between uh nihal tsar and anthon
smirnov that was great fun this one felt even more
exhilarating just because it was down to the wire
it wasn't clear who was going to win the
match until literally the very last game
so i mean what what a pleasure what a joy it
is we're spoiled honestly we really are every
match opportunity exceeds the preview i mean every
single match is is a story is a narrative it's so
much fun but unfortunately this one comes to an
end on the bright side we have of course a very
big tournament over the weekend and we have two
more semi-finals robert that are bound to be as
exciting as it gets they certainly will so on that
note you've done a great job thanking everyone
but i want to reiterate your thanks and just
really give a big shout out to all of our viewers
who continue to make this such a successful run
in the junior speeches championship for now the
action does come to a close we will come back
very shortly with the semi-finals and ultimately
to determine the champion tomorrow will be the
super swiss part of the speed chess championship
qualification process but it's time for us to say
goodbye this was the junior speeches championship
quarterfinals brought to you by chess.com
and chesskid.com until next time everybody
you